Jetzt drücke ich mal hier drauf.
Sag du mal bitte was, Gern.
Ping. Ich rede hier mal ein bisschen und jetzt lese ich deine Sticker vor.
Tu wat. Was?
Da steht tuwurst.
Da war mein, da steht gar nicht tuwurst.
Ja, das sind so ein paar Leute, die auf dem Kongress...
Das sind die Bifi-Leute.
Ich weiß gar nicht, welche Gruppe das ist.
Die müssen wir eigentlich mal Menschen an die Teilnehmer...
Free Bifi, die haben wir.
Ich versuche gerade rauszufinden, wie lange dieses Humble Bundle jetzt noch lief.
Ich glaube bis...
Wann habe ich mir denn das geholt? Vor zwei Wochen?
Was sind die Shownotes erwähnt?
Time is running out. One day is four hours thirty minutes.
Es läuft noch.
Kriegen wir es bis davor gepublished, die Folge?
Na dann, los geht's.
Hi Kian!
Hey Henrik!
Ich glaube, wir haben echt Zeitdruck, um diese Folge jetzt rauszubringen.
Wir haben nämlich wichtige Informationen, die euch alle betreffen.
Das klingt ein bisschen gehypt.
Ich glaube, viel höher als es eigentlich sein müsste.
Und zwar gibt es ein Humble Bundle, was ich mir geholt habe.
Und ich dachte eigentlich, es wäre schon längst abgelaufen.
Aber ich habe gerade auf diese Seite geguckt.
Und es läuft noch einen Tag und vier Stunden zu diesem Zeitpunkt.
Also es läuft bis Montag so um acht.
Oder um neun.
Genau, bis Montag um acht.
Krass
Also mal schauen, ob wir es heute geschnitten kriegen
Ansonsten muss ich es rausschneiden
Tut mir leid
Aber tatsächlich ist es gar nicht so krass
Ich habe ja schon ewig nicht mehr
Ein Humble Bundle mir geholt
Wann hast du das letzte Mal mit Humble Bundle?
Ich würde fast schätzen, das ist wirklich Jahre her
Also ich hatte die auch teilweise echt aus den Augen verloren
Weil ich habe mir ein, zwei Mal so ein Humble Bundle gekauft
Mit ein paar Spielen
Dann habe ich da jeweils vielleicht eins davon gespielt
Wenn überhaupt, ja
Aber die sind halt, mittlerweile haben die sich halt gut gehalten, haben weitergemacht und verkaufen halt neben Spielen auch noch allerhand anderen digitalen Content. Und das hier ist das Humble Book Bundle Functional Programming. Und das hat Jupp in unserem Firmen-Slack empfohlen und habe ich einfach mal mit einem Kollegen zusammengelegt. Es sind ein paar krasse Bücher dabei, es sind aber auch ein paar ganz schön veraltete Bücher dabei.
Also ich mache mal eine kurze Aufzählung, was da drin ist.
Living Closure, Learning Scala, Becoming Functional.
Das klingt irgendwie so ein bisschen wie so Lebensberatung.
Introducing Alexia oder Alexa, wie würdest du es aussprechen?
Oh, gute Frage.
Alexa sagen die Amis immer.
Ich finde aber Alexia irgendwie, ach, keine Ahnung.
Klingt deutscher.
Das klingt mehr nach Alchemie.
Ich mach gleich mal so weiter.
Introducing Erlang.
Erlang. Das Closure Cookbook.
Testing Scala, Scala Cookbook.
Real World Haskell, das finde ich mir am interessantesten.
Das ist aber tatsächlich ein 650 Seiten Buch.
Als ich das Gilbert vorgeschlagen habe, hat er gesagt,
ah ja, hier Märchengeschichten sind auch dabei.
Real World Haskell.
Danach kommt gleich Functional JavaScript.
Das fand ich auch ganz interessant.
die reden aber vornehmlich über
Underscore und
Zeugs, also es ist auch
das JavaScript, was sie da zeigen, ist halt auch
wahr, JavaScript quasi, das ist
alles ein bisschen dated.
Functional Thinking ist glaube ich
ein Buch, was ich tatsächlich
ja, da oben steht, das habe ich tatsächlich
auch auf Papier, das Buch.
Und wenn du den zum Vollpreis
von ich glaube 12 Dollar kaufst, dann kriegst
du noch dieses ganz neue Programming Rust
Buch dazu, was auch 600 Seiten dick ist.
Ich würde dir eigentlich das Thema gerne
durch das Ding. Ja, ich habe es bei mir
auf dem Schreibtisch im Büro liegen. Ah, cool.
Du hast es in Papierform. Ich habe es mir in Papierform
gekönnt. Das ist ein cooles Buch.
Also da sind ein paar Sachen drin, die ich vorher
ausgelassen habe.
Witzigerweise, von wem es geschrieben ist, das ist interessant.
Aber das ist nicht das Rust-Book in Papierform,
oder? Nee, das kommt erst raus.
Das kommt noch, okay. Also es gibt
N-Bücher. Es gibt das
The Rust
Program Language Edition 1, also dieses
Buch, was im Source Code mitgepflegt wird,
was von Steve Klepnik ist. Das ist auch das Buch,
was ich irgendwie zur Hälfte mal auf Deutsch übersetzt habe
mit einem anderen Typ zusammen.
Dann gibt es die Second Edition, die
Steve gerade schreibt, die jetzt mittlerweile auch
seit ein paar Tagen
in den Nightly reingefaced ist und quasi
das erste Buch ersetzt hat. Das heißt, das müsste ich
auch nochmal überlesen. Ist auch echt gut. Ich habe es mal großen Teils
überlesen gehabt. Ist echt schön. Genau, also da ist
Steve auch ziemlich stolz drauf und das ist das, was
irgendwie von...
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie der Verlag
heißt. Das wird demnächst dann auch als Buch rauskommen.
Das habe ich sogar schon vorbestellt.
nicht über O'Reilly
ne nicht über O'Reilly sondern über
No Starch Press
dann gibt es dieses
O'Reilly Buch von
Jim Blady und Jason Orendorf
das ist das aus dem als erster
Auszug dieses Why Rust
vor schon 2-3
Jahren mal rauskam als PDF
das ist quasi das Preface davon
oder das erste Kapitel davon
ist schon eine Weile raus, die haben das auch schon
vor einiger Zeit veröffentlicht.
Die beiden Autoren von dem Buch sind echt krass.
Der eine, Jim Blady, es steht auf dem
Bookcover hinten drauf, works on Firefox's
Web Developer Tools for Mozilla.
He's been maintaining
He's been maintainer of GNU
Emacs and GNU Guile
as well as GDB,
the GNU debugger.
Jim is one of the original designers of the
Subversion Versioning Control System.
Ah, witzig.
Jason Orendorf hacks C++
for Mozilla.
He is the module owner of Firefox
JavaScript Engine.
Sie saß dann, kurz nachdem ich das
in der Post gekriegt habe, saß ich mit
Henrik Skopin nochmal zusammen, der mittlerweile
übrigens mir jedes Mal, wenn er
eine Folge von uns zu Ende gehört hat, kommentiert
und mich persönlich anschreibt mit das und das
und so und so. Finde ich ganz witzig. Den möchte ich eigentlich in der nächsten
Folge unbedingt mal zu Gast haben.
Sie hat gemeint, ach ja, die beiden kenne ich.
Super cool.
Also dieses Humble Bundle könnt ihr euch noch holen.
Wie gesagt, da sind ein paar coole Bücher dabei,
vor allem wenn ihr den Vollpreis dann nehmt.
Da sind ein paar outdated Bücher dabei.
Die Skala-Bücher wollte ich mal überfliegen.
Diese generell Functional Programming-Bücher
wie Becoming Functional oder Functional Thinking
sind interessant zu lesen.
Aber eigentlich kannst du,
wenn mich jetzt jemand heute fragen würde,
was ist ein Functional Programming überhaupt,
würde ich eigentlich definieren,
du hast Immutable Variables
und dann...
Wenig State.
Hä?
Genau.
Du hast Pure Functions und du hast Filter Map Reduce.
Das ist Functional Programming.
Ich fühle mich immer schwer mit der Definition davon.
Das fühlt sich immer so simplistisch an,
aber ich glaube, Filter steckt auch viel mehr dahinter,
dass man einfach unter den Tisch fallen lässt.
Sicherlich habe ich jetzt ein, zwei Sachen vergessen.
Was irgendwie, glaube ich, nicht wirklich dazugehört,
sind algebraische Datenstrukturen.
Die haben zwar viele Funktionale der Programmiersprachen auch,
aber ich glaube nicht, dass das den funktionalen Anteil ausmacht.
Das ergibt sich eher aus dem Kontext.
Ja.
Aber das sind so Sachen, die lernt man auch echt zuerst zu schätzen, wenn man so eine Sprache mal benutzt hat.
Soviel zum Werbeblock aus unserer heutigen Folge.
Eine coole andere Reihe Bücher, die rausgekommen ist, die allerdings ziemlich random erscheint, wenn du sie dir anguckst, sind die Notes for Professionals.
Hast du da mal durchgeblättert?
Ich habe mal durchgeblättert, nachdem du mir das letztens empfohlen hattest.
Das ist so eine Sammlung von Artikeln aus diesem Stack Overflow Documentation Projekt.
Und wenn du die Bücher durchliest, die Kapitel untereinander verweisen wirklich überhaupt nicht aufeinander.
Das wird protogeneriert, oder?
Das ist irgendwie zusammengestückelt.
Ich habe da das Buch, die haben witzigerweise auf dem Cover, also ihr könnt euch das mal angucken, die sind auf goalkicker.com.
Und da gibt es Bücher zu den meisten Programmiersprachen, C, C++, JavaScript, Node.js, TypeScript, Haskell, Swift, Visual Basic, Git. Und das Schöne ist, auf dem Cover steht immer drauf, wie viele Seiten das sind.
Aber wenn du das mal durchblätterst, also das TypeScript-Buch hatte ich relativ fix durch, da sind ein, zwei Sachen drin mir aufgefallen.
Ich dachte, stimmt, das Feature kannte ich, aber habe ich noch nie benutzt, musste ich mal machen.
Das war jetzt alles nicht so geil.
Aber zum Beispiel das C++-Buch ist eigentlich ein ziemlich schöner Überblick über so ein paar Features, die man echt mal vor Augen halten müsste.
Und die Tatsache, dass es so unstrukturiert ist und einfach bloß so Niceties und Picks sind, ohne dass du jetzt, wie bei einem normalen Programmiersprachenbuch,
diese 600 Seiten 10 plus plus Bücher, die du hast,
immer wieder bei Null anfängst und dann
irgendwie Konzepte erklärst, die
eigentlich absolute
Anfängerkonzepte sind, bloß damit du
ein vollständiges Buch hast, was dir die gesamte
Programmiersprache erklären kann.
Das hast du bei diesen Büchern nicht und das ist schön.
Das hält dich halt aktiv davon ab, dass das wie ein Werk
komplett von vorne bis hinten durchzulesen.
Das ist mehr ein Nachschlagewerk, wenn du mal was
mit dir suchst oder mal schön die Inhaltsverzeichnisse
zu überfliegen und dann auch, das klingt spannend
und dann klickst du das einmal an. Ich würde Programmiersprachenbücher
glaube ich nie, also ich habe relativ viele Programmiersprachenbücher,
ich habe so einen kleinen Handapparat von diesen kleinen
Kurz und Gut O'Reilly Büchern, die ich immer mal hole.
Ich nehme die
ab und zu einfach mal mit aufs Klo.
Und das ist auch nicht, weil ich würde
aber auch nie in so ein Buch reingucken, weil ich direkt
gerade in dieser Programmiersprache programmiere und
mir jetzt irgendwie ein Feature
fehlt, was ich irgendwie, weil
so rum denkst du nicht.
Ich nehme mir so ein Buch zur Hand und dann
blätter ich durch und dann schaue ich mal,
welches Feature kenne ich noch nicht
und was könnte ich mal ausprobieren und dann lese ich mir
das durch, irgendwie so Kapitel über
Maps in dieser Sprache
oder, was weiß ich, in dieser
anderen Sprache und dann
denke ich mir, ah, das ist interessant, das versuche ich dann jetzt
in meinen Katalog mit aufzunehmen, in mein Verständnis mit
aufzunehmen und das
genau, das mache ich nicht, während ich
irgendwie konkret programmiere, sondern eher
Es hängt auch stark vom Buch ab. Es gibt auch andere,
die ganz anders geschrieben sind, zum Beispiel dieses
wie heißt das nochmal, Learn Your Herherschool for Great Good
Das liest sich ganz schön von vorne an
oder ich blätter
gerade ein bisschen so durch so ein Buch über
Serversite Swift von hackingwithswift.com
von dem Paul Hudson. Das wollte ich mir
einfach mal durchblättern. Der hat das auch ganz schön geschrieben, dass man da
wirklich
quasi wie ein Roman liest.
Echt? Also du liest wirklich
quer durch, also
eben nicht quer durch, sondern von vorne bis hinten.
So ist es gedacht. Du kannst natürlich ein bisschen umher skippen,
gerade wenn du weißt, ah klar, die thematische ist jetzt nichts
Neues oder sonst was, aber
es liest sich ganz gut, einfach so.
Dieses lineare
Durchlesen ist auch bei technischen Büchern
Was hänge ich davon ab?
Das geht eigentlich meistens nicht.
Unsere Firma hat jetzt
neulich eine Aktion, da konntest du
dir einen Kindle spendieren lassen.
So einen relativ einfachen.
Wir haben irgendwie so ein Budget für
Amazon-Gutscheine pro Monat,
dass du dir halt irgendwelche Fachbücher holst.
Dann haben sich da ein paar Leute angemeldet und haben sich
so ein Kindle da schicken lassen.
Und ein Kollege von mir hat jetzt
gesagt, ich habe das Ding wieder zurückgegeben.
Das hat er irgendwie bei
unserer
Office-Koordinatorin wieder auf den Tisch gelegt und hat gesagt,
hier kann sich jemand anders nehmen, wenn ich das,
wenn er das haben will, weil
mit dem Kindle Fachbücher lesen,
das geht einfach nicht.
Der Kindle ist dafür da, erstens ein zerstörtes
Layout, weil er es halt neue layoutet, damit
es irgendwie... Was heißt denn zerstörtes?
Digitale Bücher können nicht zerstör...
Das ist ja gerade die Idee, dass du irgendwie in EPUBs und Mobis, dass die halt
kein fest vorgebendes Format haben.
Ja, aber zumindest layoutet er den Text selber und das
eignet sich eher für Romane,
die du linear durchliest, die keine
Illustrationen haben.
Source Code ist auch ganz schrecklich.
Und das fand ich eigentlich witzigerweise cool.
Ich habe ja, wie gesagt, dieses Rust-Buch
auf Papier da.
Aber wenn ich mir das PDF hier angucke, ist der
Source Code gehighlighted in Farbe.
Das ist in der Papierform, die ich habe, ist das nicht der Fall.
Das finde ich eigentlich ganz gut.
Und der hat dann halt gemeint, ja, es ist schön, dass wir diese Aktion haben,
dass wir uns Fachbücher
bis zu einem gewissen Limit irgendwie
über Amazon schicken lassen können oder
von der Firma bezahlen lassen können.
Aber ich muss das nicht auf dem Kindle lesen oder ich möchte
das nicht auf dem Kindle lesen, weil du
ein Fachbuch über irgendwas selten
linear durchliest, sondern eher drin rumbrowsst
und skippst und da ist ein iPad einfach besser
für geeignet. Entweder das oder halt wirklich
Papierformen. Also gerade so, wenn man schnell
in den Büchern herskippt. Ja, aber dann buchst du dir ein 600-Seiten-Buch.
Nee, das bist du halt auch nicht. Das ist absolut.
Aber gerade, wie gesagt, wenn man viel durch irgendwas
durchskippen möchte, dann eignen sich irgendwie digitale
Bücher nicht ganz so sehr.
Vor allem dedizierte Geräte. Ein Kindle kann
da halt gar nicht mit klar. Ich lese ja gerne
auf dem Kindle, aber wirklich halt nur
Sachen wirklich, die du von vorne nach hinten durchliest.
das macht sich gut, weil ansonsten ist es zu viel Arbeit.
Ja, das stimmt. Sie haben zwar diese coolen
PageScript-Features, die ich noch einzig mal benutzt habe,
weil die auch total komisch sind, aber sie geben sich
halt Mühe, das da irgendwas einzubauen, dass du halt schnell
durchsteigen kannst, so eine Übersicht, aber
das bringt halt nicht viel. Die Interaktionsform mit so einem
Buch ist halt komplett anders. Ja, vor allem, weil ein E-Paper-Display
halt auch nur so viel Latenz dir geben kann
und da macht sich das auch nochmal ganz kaputt, das Ganze.
Ja, es ist,
Kindle ist meistens wesentlich kleiner
und kann keine Farbe und das macht
halt mit Illustrationen gerade, macht es
nicht schön. Also Source-Code, der
irgendwie, der umgebrochen ist
und keine Farbe hat.
Über drei Seiten am besten noch, wo du dann blättern musst.
Nee, das macht keinen Spaß.
Genau.
Ansonsten,
wenn ihr das jetzt hört und diese Sample Bundle,
diese Aktion schon durchgelaufen ist, ein, zwei von den Büchern
habe ich auch in Hardstar.
Die gibt er gerne aus, oder wie?
Vielleicht gibt er mir mal
einen Kaffee aus und dann kann ich die euch vielleicht mal ausleihen.
Genau.
Ja, soviel zum Thema
Literaturtipp der Woche.
Neue Sektion.
Ansonsten haben wir auch so ein anderes
Reoccurring-Theme, den
NPM-Fuck-Up des Monats.
War ja wieder schön jetzt
gewesen. Was ist denn diesmal passiert,
Kira, erzähl mal. Was haben sie geschafft? Sie haben
eine Version gepublished von NPM
als Pre-Release, die irgendwie nicht ganz
sauber als Pre-Release erkennbar war. Viele Leute haben
sie installiert und das Ding hat, wenn du
NPM mit Sudorechten ausgeführt hast,
so wie ich das verstanden habe, dann hat der
versucht, deine Rechte zu deeskalieren
auf dich als Nutzer
und dabei irgendwelche Rechte umgeschrieben
mit deinem Dateisystem, was böse
Nebenwirkungen hatte, dass
nichts mehr ging. Also ich nutze
NPM nicht, ich habe keine Ahnung, was genau da passiert ist,
aber what?
Don't be smart about shit, vor allem.
Ja, also was
irgendwie passiert ist, ist, dass die
Version 5.7.0
publishen wollten, als
Pre-Release. Bei NPM gibt es ja
diese Release-Channels
auch noch. Also es gibt unterschiedliche Versionen, wie man
Semware einen Release markieren kann.
Da hast du entweder diese
dreistellige Release-Version
und dann hast du hintendran RC
oder Pre
oder Beta oder Alpha.
Das haben sie nicht gemacht, sondern bei
MPM gibt es Channels und da steht dann entweder
dran Latest oder
Next. Und zu dem Zeitpunkt war
Latest 5.6.0 und
Next war 5.7.0.
Wie genau äußern sich denn diese Channels?
War das Tag
Latest und das Tag Next, was auch auf
zeigt oder was? Du kannst es auf
NPM, kannst du NPM-Pakete
in so einen Channel reinreleasen. Also du kannst,
wenn du in deine
Package-JSON, die Dependency
reinschreibst, kannst du auch add next oder
add latest reinschreiben. Und Channels
sind dann unterschiedliche Listen an Versions-Identifiants,
die für die Pakete relevant sind.
So grob wie ich das verstehe, ja.
Okay, also kann man sich dann, okay, war gut.
Zumindest, was sie halt gemacht haben, ist,
die haben das unter
5.7.0
als Pre-Release
veröffentlicht. Du siehst der Version 5.7.0
aber nicht an, dass das ein Pre-Release ist,
weil so wie das aussieht, steht ja nicht
Pre oder das gibt es halt auch.
In Semware kannst du in die Version
reinschreiben, Dash, Alpha, Beta,
Pre, was weiß ich.
RC habe ich ein paar Mal benutzt gehabt.
1, 2, 3 und so weiter und so fort.
Das können viele Semware-Parser
auch verstehen.
Der Rust-Semware-Parser
kann das ohne weiteres mitpausen.
Haben sie nicht gemacht.
Und was sie zusätzlich auch noch gemacht haben, ist, dass sie einen Blogpost veröffentlicht haben über Version 5.7.0, wo nicht einmal das Wort Pre-Release drin vorkommt, wo sie halt über die neuen Features informieren.
Was echt, wenn du jetzt nicht drauf guckst, denkst du, es ist released worden.
Sie haben es ja auf GitHub als Pre-Release markiert, aber das sagt ja überhaupt nichts aus.
Ich meine, da musst du einerseits die GitHub-UI für die Releases anschauen, wo du dann dieses orangene Pre-Release-Tag an der Seite siehst, aber das wird ja überhaupt nicht wieder gespiegelt in den Git-Tags, die GitHub-Releases.
Leute, die einfach generell auf...
Mir stört das auch, wenn Leute komplett GitHub-Infrastruktur
für irgendwas nutzen und zu tun,
ob das hier jetzt der Status Quo ist.
GitHub ist doch auch nicht für immer.
Viele Leute, die pendeln jetzt komplett auf GitHub
und irgendwann wird das mal wegfallen
und plötzlich ist alles im Arsch oder was.
Da gab es noch einen anderen weiteren Faktor,
hast du den mitbekommen?
Nee.
GitHub hat bei sich für die Clients
eine Änderung gemacht.
Genau.
Steht February 23rd,
We Cryptographic Standards Removed.
And zwar,
Okay.
Early today,
we permanently removed support
for the following
weak cryptographic standards
in github.com
and api.github.com.
TAS V1
and TAS V1.1.
This applies to all
HTTPS connections,
including Web API
and Git connections.
Diffie-Hellman Group 1
SHA 1.
This applies to all
SSH connections to GitHub.
Diffie-Hellman Group 14
SHA 1.
This applies to all
SSH connections
on github.com.
Okay.
ähm, prinzipiell
wäre ja ganz schön
das Problem ist, dass dann alle Windows 7
Clients nicht mehr funktionieren
oh nein
so, jetzt gibt es irgendwie die
den
die Rust Leute haben das
zumindest über den Cargo Channel auf Twitter
gepostet, ich hab's bloß so
am Vorbeiscrollen gesehen, dass die halt
Windows 7 Nutzern
empfehlen, diese und jene Maßnahmen zu ergreifen
also wird das auch nicht
quasi wieder zu revertet
Windows 7 nutzt, sondern die müssen einfach irgendwie das selber fixen.
Jetzt müssen sie irgendwie Windows 7
beibringen, aktuellere Krypto zu verwenden.
Und was genau heißt denn das?
Die können jetzt nicht mehr TLS mit GitHub sprechen,
oder was? Die können nicht mehr TLS
1.1 und 1.0 mit GitHub sprechen,
ja. Im Endeffekt benutzt,
im Endeffekt funktioniert es so,
dass viele Clients benutzen ja diese LibGit 2
und LibGit 2
bringt ja selber keine Krypto
mit, sondern benutzt irgendwie Systemlibraries,
zum Beispiel von Windows oder OpenSSL
und dementsprechend benutzt es auf Windows 7
die Sachen, die Windows mitbringt.
Und was sie jetzt machen können,
ist, dass sie dir eine gepatchte
Git-Version mitbringen, die
das einfach selber mitbringt und updatet,
wenn du Windows 7-Nutzer bist.
Und ansonsten, ich weiß nicht,
wie das Problem gelöst ist. Soweit ich weiß,
ist es zu diesem Zeitpunkt noch nicht gelöst.
Witzig. Aber man hätte
der Meinung sein können, dass das GitHub sowas
vielleicht selber mitbekommt?
Das kann auch sein, dass die sagen,
Hört mal, es gibt mittlerweile wie altes Windows 10 jetzt?
Ja, aber Windows 7 ist doch immer noch ein sehr weit verbreitetes System.
Da gibt es doch viele Leute, die das nutzen.
Ich kenne ganze Firmen, die ausschließlich Windows 7 benutzen.
Wenn überhaupt.
Sind sie auf XP oder so?
Ja, krass.
Das älteste Supporter für Windows ist Vista.
Ist das noch supported?
Ich dachte, wenn XP jetzt erst vor nicht allzu langer Zeit ausgelaufen ist,
oder war XP einfach noch extra lang supported,
weil das der Standard
ist für so lange Zeit.
Müssen wir mal nachgucken?
Ich weiß aber auch,
ich überhaupt nicht, also ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es auf Windows 7 ist
und niemand mehr wisst, da nur zwei.
Latest Release Service Pack 2, 26. Mai 2009,
8 years ago.
Mainstream Support
endet,
Extended Support endet
2017, also wisst ihr, dass es nicht mehr supported?
Wisst ihr, dass es auch ausgelaufen ist?
Interessant zu wissen.
Und soweit ich weiß, läuft Windows 8
gleichzeitig mit Windows 7
aus demnächst.
Was 8 läuft auch schon aus. Das heißt,
in Supported ist nur noch Windows 10.
Da können wir es jetzt auch einfach machen bei Microsoft.
Supported ist das aktuelle Release mehr nicht. Pech.
Ja, es ist auch
so eine Unart, dass die Leute einfach
ihre Software nicht
updaten.
Das ist manchmal schwieriger als...
Das ist ganz schlimm, ja. Aber zum Beispiel diese
Tatsache, dass das ist so ein
Storshift, muss ich sagen, der stattfindet.
Also aktuelle
Software, die man benutzt,
Compiler gerade oder
Programmiersprachen oder Programmier-Runtimes,
da weiß man,
dass da regelmäßig
Releases kommen. Wir leben schließlich
im Internet-Zeitalter, man lädt sich einfach über
Paketmanager eine neue Version runter, macht ein paar
Updates und dann hat man das released.
Aber viel Software, gerade so
aus der Windows-Welt oder aus der
C++-Code, da war es ja
bis vor ein paar Jahren überhaupt nicht.
Usus, dass das geupdatet wurde, da hing man dann
auf den Versionen, die einem irgendeine
Linux-Distro
mitgegeben hat zum Beispiel, oder
irgendeine Visual Studio-Version,
für die man noch eine Lizenz hatte,
hat man da benutzt. Und wenn es da was Neues gab,
das Updaten ist ein Riesenakt.
Und gerade
das Schlimmste ist
eigentlich,
das Schlimmste ist eigentlich, dass
Compiler an Distros dranhängen.
Das ist eigentlich gut, aber
auf der anderen Seite, du schreibst eine Software,
irgendeine Server-Software, die muss auf irgendeinem
Betriebssystem laufen, zum Beispiel
irgendein Solaris oder irgendein Red Hat.
Dann musst du
deinen Code so schreiben,
dass das auf dem
Compiler
kompiliert werden kann,
auf der Distro, auf der du es zum Schluss laufen lassen
möchtest. Das heißt, wenn du
irgendwie eine Serverflotte hast,
die auch noch so
handgestreichelt ist, wo irgendeine
stabile, aber alte Version von irgendeinem
hinläuft, dann kannst du halt auch deinen Source-Code nicht
mit einem neueren Compiler bauen.
Was dann teilweise
Repercussions auf anderer Ebene hat,
dann kann dein Entwickler einen bestimmten
Compiler bei sich nicht nutzen,
weil der keinen kompatiblen Code produziert
oder vielleicht die alten Sachen nicht mehr unterstützt.
Also es ist alles
gut, dass wir uns langsam
aus dieser Gegend wieder wegtregen.
Das ist interessant, ja.
Mittlerweile deployen alle ihr Zeugs auf
Docker und können dann mal eben sagen, gut,
jetzt baue ich das mal mit einem aktuelleren
Ubuntu-Image? Hast du diesen
wunderschönen Tweet
letztens zu der spekulierten Geschichte
von Docker gelesen gehabt?
Der hat irgendeinen Dresdler, der das
gebraucht hat, einer von den Mathematikern.
Ops, it doesn't run.
Well, it works on my machine.
Ops, fine, then we ship your machine.
And thus, kids, Docker was born.
Von dem Twitter,
das ist some penguins.
Absolut losrottig. Ich bin jetzt neulich
von einem amerikanischen Kollegen
angeschrieben worden.
Letzten Mittwoch, so um 22 Uhr.
Ja,
hier in unserem Bildsystem hat sich irgendwie was geändert.
Hast du da was umgestellt? Da ist plötzlich
dieses npm-run-Script nicht mehr drauf.
Wie? npm-run-Script ist nicht mehr drauf.
Ja, wir konnten
früher npm mit diesem Shell-Script da
ausführen. So, warum macht
ihr das? Ja, also wir haben
dieses, wir haben, all unsere Zeugs sind
in einem Repo und da arbeiten Leute, die in dem Projekt
arbeiten, arbeiten in dem Repo und Leute,
die an ganz anderen Projekten arbeiten, sind an dem
Repo dran. Und
mir war zu dem
Zeit, viele Leute arbeiten entweder nur
an C++-Code und arbeiten dann aus Visual Studio
raus und manche Leute arbeiten zum Beispiel nur an dem
JavaScript-Code und arbeiten dann nur aus Jahren raus
oder sowas. Oder aus NPM
raus, wenn sie irgendwas bauen, dann sagen sie halt
NPM-Install oder Build, so.
Relativ straightforward. Und dann
gibt es aber auch Leute, die arbeiten
in Docker-Images, wenn sie es bauen
und relien darauf, dass da
irgendein Shell-Script in dem Repo
mit drin liegt, was NPM-wrappt, um
welche Cores auszuführen.
Das war auch ein Use Case,
der mir noch nicht untergekommen ist zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Das hatten wir dann irgendwann beim Aufräumen des Bildsystems
mal umbenannt
oder umverschoben irgendwo anders hin.
Und es ist direkt
irgendwelchen Leuten auf die Füße gefallen.
Das verpassen der XKCD mit dem
You broke my workflow.
Den können wir gleich mal in die Shownotes tun.
Aber wo ja gerade
dabei waren, dass die Leute offenbar alle
Semware nicht richtig verstehen. Wollen wir mal ein bisschen über
Semware reden? Klar, hau raus.
Also ich packe mal in die Show Notes
semware.org
Semantic Versioning ist
ein Versionierungsschema
Kennst du unterschiedliche Versioning Schemes
für Software?
Mir fällt immer dieses eine ein, das war so ein Witz
nicht Semantic Versioning, sondern
ich habe immer im Kopf, das heißt Empathetic Versioning
es hieß aber anders
das was Latex zum Beispiel macht
die sich immer weiter mit einer Version P annähern
das ist halt ein Witz
War es nicht bei Perl so, dass sie sich
oder 6 angenähert haben und als nie erreicht
haben oder sowas. Zumindest
gibt es unterschiedliche Versioning-Schemes
in dieser Welt da draußen für unterschiedliche
Use Cases und
das ist genauso wie mit
Serialisierungsformaten, wo vor
20 Jahren noch jeder seinen eigenen Syntax
und sein eigenes Serialisierungsformat
erfunden hat. Mittlerweile einigen sich die Leute
so auf ein paar Common Candidates
sowas wie JSON oder
Protobuf oder
ja, ein Logfiles,
in einem komplett anderen Format geschrieben sind, oder bin ich davon.
Aber bei Versioning-Schemes
gibt es halt auch unterschiedliche. Der Linux-Kernel
hatte irgendwie ein sehr
komisches Versioning-Scheme. Die haben einfach
hinten immer eine Zahl hochgezählt,
bis irgendwann Linus immer wieder das
Gefühl hatte, wir müssen mal wieder eine Major-Version
hochzählen, obwohl es irgendwie keine große Bedeutung
hatte. Dementsprechend gab es dann plötzlich doch
Linux 3 und dann gab es doch irgendwann Linux 4
und es ist nicht ganz
so angemessen.
Schöne Versioning-Schemes, finde ich, sind solche,
wie das von Ubuntu zum Beispiel,
weil einfach immer eine neue Version
rauskommt und die einfach aktuell
gepackaged ist mit neuen Paketen
und das geht einfach kontinuierlich
weiter und die Version drückt überhaupt nicht aus
wie sich diese Version zur vorherigen verhält
sondern es ist einfach die neue Version
also steht da das Datum drin, nämlich
18.04, 17.10
einfach das Jahr und der Monat, wann es rauskommt
Das ist auch schön, wann es rauszukommen ist gleich
Aber gerade für den End-User macht ja vieles auch nicht so Sinn
der Unterschied zwischen Major und Minor
Genau, bei Linux
beim Linux-Könnel könnten sie eigentlich genau das
gleiche machen, aber da stecke ich nicht so drin, warum sie das da
nicht machen. Bei Firefox
haben sie ja auch irgendwann gesagt, ach wisst ihr was,
wir bringen einfach immer eine
neue Version raus, die sind jetzt
mittlerweile bei 55
oder 57, nee 57 war
dieser große Quantum Release, also
bei 58 oder 59, aber
wer verfolgt das schon noch so genau?
Wer kommt da nicht auch dafür, einfach nur weil bei Chrome angefangen
hat, so schnell hochzuzählen, müssten sie ja mitziehen.
Genau, also die Browser sind alle so in den zweistelligen
Versionen. Also Chrome ist irgendwo mit der
momentan. Safari ist bei 11.
Die anderen sind, ja,
Safari kommt irgendwie nicht ganz so schnell.
Was heißt denn, das sagt überhaupt nichts aus, diese scheiß Versionsnummern.
Naja, aber so
dreistellige Versionsnummern, wo du vorne
Major, Minor und dann hinten eine Patch-Version hast,
sind halt für solche Produkte oder gerade
eine Marketing-Version,
da ist das
ja gar nicht so interessant. Da möchtest du einfach bloß dem
Nutzer sagen, hier, das ist aktueller als das.
Wenn du allerdings
Software verwendest,
die eine API hat,
zum Beispiel eine Library, wie zum Beispiel
so eine NPM-Library oder ein NPM selber.
Also bei NPM selber ist es gar nicht so interessant,
welche Version das konkret hat, ob das nur Semantic
Versioning ist oder nicht. Aber wenn ich zum Beispiel
eine Library anbiete, die ein Public
Interface hat, dann möchte ich mit dieser Version,
wo Leute drauf dependen, in einer
Package-Chasing oder in einer Cargo-Tommel oder
in einer, wie heißt das beim Swift? Package-Swift.
Package-Swift. Dann möchte ich
damit demjenigen, der es benutzt,
sagen können, okay, du kannst sicher innerhalb
von dieser Range updaten und wenn du
die erste Zahl 1 hochzielst, in der
dann musst du eventuell hier was nachbessern, weil was kaputt geht.
Da drückt das schon mal viel mehr aus, auf jeden Fall.
Genau.
Und das nennt sich Semantic Versioning.
Semantic Versioning ist dieses Schema, wo du
drei Versionsstellen hast,
nämlich Major, Minor und
Patch. Und eine
Major-Versionsänderung heißt, du hast Breaking
Changes und hast Änderungen. Eine
Minor-Versions-Change heißt, du hast
Änderungen, aber es bleibt
alles, was bis jetzt da ist, verhält sich und
sieht genauso aus, wie es ist und es kommen höchstens
Sachen dazu. Und Patch-Version
ist, es hat sich absolut überhaupt nichts geändert,
außer dass wir ein paar Bugs gefixt
haben und du solltest diese Version auch immer updaten.
Und da
hinten dran kannst du dann noch ein Prefix
hängen mit Pre, Alpha,
ein Suffix hängen, genau, oder
Predicate heißt es, glaube ich, sogar.
Genau.
Dann gibt es noch andere Syntaxen
für Semantic Versioning.
Diese Tilde
und diese
Carry-Schreibweise vorne dran.
Semantic Version, also
Also es gibt eine...
Ach, du meinst jetzt für so Version Requirements, wo du sagst?
Version Requirements, genau. Es gibt eine harte Version,
aber in den Package Manager schreibst du ja meistens
Version Requirement rein. Das ist entweder,
ist das dann zum Beispiel
kleiner gleich diese Version.
Das macht auch jeder Package Manager komplett anders.
Das macht jeder Package Manager komplett anders.
Ganz schrecklich.
Das ist leider von Semware.org.
Die beschreiben zwar,
was Semantic Versioning ist, aber die
beschreiben nicht, wie die Syntax auszusehen hat.
Das ist ein bisschen schade. Dementsprechend
wir haben ja das letzte Mal schon darüber geredet, ich habe zum Spaß angefangen
hier ein bisschen Paketmanagement
für NPM-Pakete in Rust
zu bauen und
es ist mir in dem Moment auf die Füße gefallen,
als ich den Packagemanager,
den Jarn-Log-File-Parser in Rust schon fertig
geschrieben hatte und ich dachte, das geht eigentlich
und dann habe ich mal eine andere Log-File geparst
und es ist vollkommen umgefallen, weil
die Versionen, die da drin stehen, von dem
Semware-Rust-Create überhaupt nicht
parsbar waren.
Dann musste ich quasi nochmal einen anderen Parser dafür schreiben.
ähm, genau, also du kannst
vorne Semware kannst du vorschreiben
Tilde
das heißt, oh jetzt bring ich es selber durcheinander
in welcher Welt? Rust? In der NPM-Welt
NPM, okay
du kannst Tilde
da vorschreiben, das heißt gib mir
ja, jetzt muss ich selber nachdenken
genau das ist halt, das ist das Problem, genau
im Endeffekt, also eins von beiden
heißt, schaut's bitte selber nach
eins von beiden
heißt, ihr könnt die
Major-Version hochzählen und
das andere heißt, ihr könnt die
meiner Version hochzählen. Und warum man die
Major-Version hochzählbar machen können sollte,
kann ich absolut nicht nachvollziehen, weil bei
NPM-Paketen hast du teilweise bei Patch-Versionen
Breaking Changes drin, weil die Leute einfach nicht
verstehen, wie man Zembers benutzt. Beziehungsweise
weil eine Sprache wie JavaScript es
auch dir absolut unmöglich macht, zu
verifizieren, dass du deine API nicht verändert hast.
Dann hast du ja teilweise auch so
schöne Sachen, das habe ich neulich in einem anderen
Podcast gehört, if you break your API,
break it hard.
Das heißt, wenn du wirklich irgendwo
Breaking Changes hast, dass du
Behavior hast, was sich ändert, dann benenn bitte
auch die Funktionen um oder mach es, dass der alte
Code nicht mehr kompiliert.
Damit die Leute auch wirklich da merken,
oh, hier ändert sich was.
Und dann wirklich an der Stelle genau nachgucken müssen,
wie sie es jetzt verändern.
Das ist auch was, was wichtig ist und was viele Leute
irgendwie nicht wirklich im Blick haben.
Übrigens, gerade habe ich gestern gesehen,
Swift ist beim
Google Summer of Code mit dabei.
Diverses am Swift-Ökosystem,
also vor allem auch Compiler und Package-Manager
und alles. Und ein
ausgeschriebenes Projekt für den Package-Manager
ist ein Recommender,
der dir sagt, keine Ahnung,
wenn du beispielsweise
Swift-Package-Bump ausführst, der dir sagt,
was aufgrund deiner API-Changes eine
sinnvolle nächste Versionsnummer sein könnte.
Finde ich super cool. Das ist ja auch, was du mal mit
Gilbert für Rust ähnlich geplant hattest.
Ja, da hätte ich fast mal eine Diplomarbeit drüber geschrieben, ist nie zuständig
gekommen. Aber die Leute wünschen sich das immer noch
für Rust, weil es prinzipiell durchaus möglich wäre
anhand der Signaturen
und des Public Interfaces deiner
Scrates zu sehen, ob das jetzt noch mit
der Version kompatibel ist oder nicht. Wahrscheinlich ist es
aber schwierig auch, viele Dinge da
mit reinfließen, gerade auf Swift bezogen.
Ich meine, wenn du in dem Iman
einen neuen Case hinzufügst, das ist an sich ein Breaking Change,
weil dann, wenn
du Exhaustive Pattern Magic machen möchtest,
das dann nicht mehr funktioniert.
Also es ist ein Breaking Change. Es gibt
noch Unterschiede zwischen, die Leute unterscheiden
zwischen Minor und Major
Breaking Changes. Okay, jetzt
kommen wir auf eine sehr interessante Gefilde.
Ja, das kann ich ganz noch
kurz abhaken, bevor ich dann
zu hier unseren Negativbeispielen
komme. Also der Fall,
du fügst einen
Inum Case hinzu und ist
ein kleiner Breaking Change.
Das heißt, du kannst das, in der Rust-Welt würde
sowas noch kein
Major-Version-Bump requiren,
weil es
einfach zu fixen ist.
Dein Code kompiliert nicht mehr,
Dein Kunde kompiliert nicht mehr, du musst halt
noch ein Case
mehr matchen, aber
ist das denn im Endeffekt
nur was dazugekommen.
Achso, es ist ein Additive Breaking Challenge.
Es ist ein Additive. Du hast jetzt nicht
bestehendes Verhalten geändert oder
was weggenommen.
Das ist halt die Frage, kannst du das wirklich
sagen, dass jeder Client
jetzt einfach noch einen neuen Ignored Case
quasi hinzufügt oder ob man der das
explizit abfangen muss, weil der vorher da irgendwie
Magic drin hat. Du weißt halt nicht sicher,
wie der Client damit umgeht, das ist halt
echt schwierig, sowas zu generalisieren.
Das stimmt, aber es ist in jedem Fall
auch immer wieder so ein bisschen
gut dünken dabei. Also du musst immer auch
genau hingucken, deswegen kannst du auch,
selbst wenn du aufgrund der API
entscheidest, hier
sind nur Sachen
dazugekommen,
das sollte kein Breaking Change sein.
Deswegen sag ich, es gibt aber auch Fälle, wo zum Beispiel
in Sprachen, wo du kein anständiges
Typsystem hast, so C++ zum Beispiel,
wo du APIs hast,
da gab es nämlich einen schönen Vortrag von Scott Myers,
den ich gesehen habe,
der hat sich beschwert,
dass du irgendeine Mail-App in Apple hast,
da stehen vier Icons drin
und wenn du die aber von Portrait-Modus
auf Landscape-Modus kippst,
dann sind diese vier Icons,
die genau in dieser gleichen Toolbar stehen,
einfach komplett anders sortiert,
und zwar an einer Permutation,
wo jeder an einer anderen Position ist.
Und so hast du es auch bei C-APIs,
da hast du APIs,
wo du eine Liste von entweder Integern reingest,
reinkriegst, die mal
eine Zahl sind, mal irgendein
Limit, mal ist es ein
File Descriptor oder wo du
Pointer reinkriegst, die mal am Anfang von
einem String sind oder von einem Array, die kannst du
auch frei umsortieren und das
ist dann das, wo ich sage, wo ich gesagt habe
if you change your
API, break it hard.
Weil du kannst ohne weiteres
solche Weekly-Typed
APIs umsortieren
und hast trotzdem noch Code, der
kompiliert, aber hinterher halt buggy ist.
im Arsch, ja. Deswegen sind Argument-Labels
was Schönes in Swift, finde ich.
Ja, oder du nimmst einfach
ein Objekt an,
was Keys hat.
Zum Beispiel in Ruby oder JavaScript
hast du häufig auch APIs, da hast du
keine
Positional Parameters in Funktionen oder Arguments.
Ich verwechsel immer, ob man Arguments oder Parameters sagt.
Nur Spy is interchangeable.
Sondern die nehmen einfach ein Objekt an und schauen, ob in dem Objekt
diese Keys drin sind.
Wir faken uns Argument-Labels,
wo wir keine haben in den Sprachen rein.
Genau.
Finde ich aber auch,
mir macht es natürlich viel einfacher,
so ein API zu abusen,
wenn es auch aus Versehen ist.
Da kannst du nicht mehr aus Versehen Scheiße reingeben,
weil er halt ein bisschen mehr verifizieren kann,
was deine Paralyse da auch sind.
Finde ich echt sinnvoll.
In Ruby haben sie dafür dann auch
ein bisschen Syntax-Shoggle irgendwann erfunden,
dass du das einfach so reingeben kannst.
Ja, da bin ich jetzt aber ein bisschen hinterher.
Wir sind neulich von Jan Leles empfohlen worden auf Twitter.
Yay, grüße.
Den müssen wir auch mal dazu als Gast einladen.
das ist, glaube ich, der absolute
Ruby-Goo. Bevor wir über Ruby reden, sollten wir
uns da jemanden holen.
In Python ist es ja auch so,
da ist ja auch gang und gäbe einfach, dass du
vieles über Default Params machst und die musst du
ja dann benannt angeben.
Und dann ist die Reihenfolge auch völlig nicht total egal,
wie du die angibst, sondern du gibst halt den Namen mit an.
Du gibst quasi Dictionary
damit rein. Was ja
wirklich sinnvoll ist, in dem Sinne
ist es ja nicht mehr eine Funktion,
wo du A und B reingibst,
sondern du gibst ja einen State,
deine Funktion ein. Das ist so viel lesbarer, du kannst so viel
einfach verstehen, was was macht. Aber gehen wir
zurück zu den Leuten, die sich eigentlich mit
Semware auskennen sollten und es nicht tun.
Nämlich zum Beispiel NPM und
Jan.
Zwei Paketmanager und
NPM hat halt diesen
schönen Pre-Release, den ja kein Pre-Release
oder nicht als Pre-Release zu erkennen war, rausgebracht,
wo wir gerade drüber geredet haben.
Mir wurde gerade Jan empfohlen,
hier gibt es doch jetzt Version 1.5, da ist das
und das drin. Ich schaue nochmal auf die Startseite von
von Jahren und da steht tatsächlich
momentan sind
zwei Versionen released, nämlich
Version 1.3.2
das ist der
Stable und dann gibt es Versionen
1.4.0 ist der
Release Candidate, aber wenn du dir das
in deine Package-JSON als Dependency reinschreibst
ich meine, du installierst es dir nicht als Dependency, weil es eine
Binary ist, aber dann installierst, schreibst
du einfach rein 1.4.0
wenn du diese Package-JSON dir anguckst, siehst du nicht, dass
das ein Release Candidate ist
es wird auch nie ein anderer
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie die das machen wollen, wenn die
1.4.0 als nicht mehr Release
Candidate rausbringen wollen, wie drückst du das dann aus?
Kriege ich dann plötzlich einfach ein Update, weil ich
die gleiche Version drin gestiegen habe und habe
eine andere Version als vorher? Die taggen eine andere Version
als 1.4.0, einen anderen Commit als 1.4.0
und sagen, hey, das hier ist jetzt nicht mehr das
Vim-Geta-Tanel. Das heißt, ich habe eine Package-Jasen,
da kann ich, ich meine, ich kann in so einen
Dependency-Eintrag reinschreiben, entweder eine,
wie wir gerade definiert haben,
eine Version-Requirement mit einer Range,
ja, oder
eine harte Version, wo einfach drinsteht
1-4-0 hart.
Da erwarte ich eigentlich, dass ich immer
die gleiche Version kriege, weil es gibt nur diese Version.
Wenn die es allerdings selber,
wenn selbst die Jahren-Leute einen Release-Candidate
einfach 1-4-0 nennen
und dann,
ich weiß nicht, irgendwann 1-4-0
stable machen, als
stable releasen,
gibt es ja nochmal eine andere Version. Ist das dann genau
der gleiche Code? Wenn die
jetzt nochmal was ändern, ist das dann 1-4-1?
Also irgendwie gehen die mit diesem ganzen Konzept
nicht in einer nachvollziehbaren Art und Weise um.
Und dann passieren halt genau so Sachen,
dass Leute
NPM 5.7.0
halt als Release anerkennen
und sich sagen,
warum fällt das
jetzt hier plötzlich um?
Und dann werden sie halt diesen
GitHub-Issue-Thread,
da haben Leute irgendwann einfach nur noch
Popcorn-Emojis gepostet.
Die haben sich gegenseitig mit einem Ton
angesprochen, das ist eigentlich nicht würdig
gewesen.
Und da haben tatsächlich
echt auch NPM-Mitarbeiter
gesagt, was benutzt ihr denn auch?
Pre-Releases,
neuer Production-Code, ja Deppen und sowas.
Das ist einfach nicht feierlich.
Oh Gott. Da hat man schon
Semantic-Versioning, so eine Spezifikation,
auf die man sich einigt und dann
gehen selbst die Leute, die Paketmanager
schreiben, mit so einer grobschlechtigen
Art und Weise mit diesem Konzept um.
Das ist eigentlich traurig.
Ja, halten wir fest, es wäre schöner, wenn Leute
Pre-Releases auch sowas
als markieren würden in dem
Version-Tag direkt mit drin, dass es auch fest
bleibt auf diesem Commit, das Version-Tag
und wenn irgendwann die Version rauskommt
und kein Pre-Release mehr ist, dann hat es ein anderes Tag
was aber dieselbe Version hat, aber
kein Pre-Release-Identifier mit drinstehen hat
Das wäre schön
Also ich wünsche mir, dass
Semware.org
Die haben ja
es sind ja selber versioniert, es gibt von Semware
gibt es Version 1.0.0.
Es gab eine 1.0.0 Beta. Es gab eine
2.0.0 Release 1.0.
Release Candidate 2.0.0.
Ich wünsche mir für die 3.0.0
von Semware, dass die hart die
Syntax und die Möglichkeiten, die es gibt,
definieren. Du meinst auch, dass man
wie eine Version
auszusehen hat,
wie so ein Suffix,
also Alpha, Beta, Release Candidate
auszusehen hat und wie eine
Version Range zu lesen ist.
Diese Version Range, das finde ich tatsächlich,
manche Leute mögen das nicht, aber ich finde das echt
angenehm, wie Swift das macht in dem
Package Manifest. Da sagst du nicht irgendwelche
obskuren Operatoren,
ob das jetzt dieser Tilde
Größe, also so ein Squiggly-File, der
irgendwas macht wie in CocoaPods, glaube ich, oder
wie gesagt, wie bei jedem Package Manager komplett anders
gehandhabt wird. Für Swift
selber machst du das so, dass
der da, das ist ja auch Swift die Manifest-Datei,
da kommt ein Inam rein oder da gibt es ein paar
Overloads, die da reinpacken, entweder from
und ein String, direkt eine Version, dann ist das diese
Version und ich glaube, das impliziert dann ab dem
Das ist noch ein bisschen Magic. Aber ansonsten kannst du auch Punkt up to next major oder Punkt up to next minor.
Ich weiß, was damit gemeint ist. Natürlich sind ein paar Zeichen mehr zum Tippen. Das brauchst du aber nicht oft.
Und dann ist es ganz klar, was damit gemeint ist.
Vielleicht könntest du einfach ein Beispiel in die Show noch schreiben.
Du schreibst halt wirklich up to next minor.
Wie es in der Cargo-Termine steht, finde ich auch relativ schön.
Da hast du teilweise nicht drei Stellen stehen. Da hast du nicht 1.0.0 drin stehen.
da hast du nur 1.0 drinstehen.
Und dann matcht halt so viel, wie passt,
nimmt der da raus.
Wenn du bei dir 1 reinschreibst,
dann ist einfach nur alles, was kleiner 2 ist.
Finde ich gut.
Das geht,
soweit ich weiß, auch bei NPM.
Aber bei NPM haben sich die Leute angewöhnt,
so obskure mathematische Versionsranges
hinzuschreiben, wo echt kleiner gleich drinsteht
oder nur wirklich kleiner als Version 2.0.
Und du denkst,
das kann man auch wesentlich einfacher ausdrücken.
Das ist mir bloß letzte Woche auf die Physik gefallen,
weil ich dafür einen Parser schreiben musste.
Aber das geht überhaupt nicht.
Hast du diesen Parser? Was hast du denn da gebaut?
Ich hatte ja vielleicht beim letzten Mal schon erzählt,
dass ich ein bisschen rumspiele
und überlege,
wie gesagt, das geht wirklich nicht gezielt
irgendwohin, aber ich habe zum Spaß, weil ich auf Arbeit merke,
dass diese Software im JavaScript alles keine
Qualität hat.
Also überlegt habe ich, wie kompliziert
wäre es eigentlich, einen Package Manager für
NPM in Rust zu schreiben. Ich hatte ja mal
mit Zerre ein bisschen als Demo
einfach mal Jens Gema
geschrieben
für Package-Jasons
und da war es halt schön, dass du an der Stelle, wo
Version steht, konntest du in deine
Struct einfach reinschreiben,
da kommt kein String rein, da kommt
ein Semware-Typ rein und
dadurch, dass Semware oder URL
geht genauso, dass dieses Semware-Objekt
serialized und deserialized
selber implementiert, from String,
kannst du tatsächlich da einfach das
rein serialisieren und dann hast du da
ein Semware-Objekt, das du fragen kannst, bist du
oder größer als das, oder matchst du
auf diese Range. Genauso ist es halt bei URL.
Da hast du reingeschrieben, du bist eine URL
und wenn nicht, dann ist das halt keine valide URL.
Das ist eigentlich ganz cool.
Schick, typisierte Versuchzeit-Interfile.
Genau.
Da dachte ich, gehe ich mal ein bisschen weiter,
bis ich dann halt irgendwann gesehen habe, dass eine Cargo-Log-File
ein eigenes Serialisierungsformat ist.
Und dann muss ich dafür einen Parser schreiben.
Du meinst die
MPM-Log?
Also Cargo?
Package-Manager haben eine
Manifest-Datei, Cargo
Toml, Package.json,
Package.swift
oder Gemfile.
Die Manifest-Datei.
Es gibt auch eine Manifest-Datei und bei den
meisten Seiten, seit Bundler, gibt es auch eine Log-Datei.
So, bei Cargo ist das eine
cargo.log, ist aber auch bloß eine Toml-Datei.
Bei NPM5 gab es das,
da gab es dann eine package-log.json,
das ist eine JSON-Datei.
Bei yarn heißt das
yarn.log und ist ein komplett
eigenes Format. Das sieht
grob aus wie Jammel, ist aber keine
Jammel-Syntax.
Almost entirely not quite
unlike Jammel.
Ja,
also ich habe überlegt, ob ich beim nächsten Rust-Meetup
hier in Dresden mal über NOM-Rede, damit
habe ich ja schon mal ein bisschen rumgespielt. Mittlerweile
steige ich da mehr und mehr durch, aber
so richtig trivial ist es immer noch nicht.
Ja, also zumindest
wie sind wir da hingekommen?
Zimmer. Stimmerpausen.
Also nicht Stimmerpausen. Genau, also
Und da habe ich dann einfach geschrieben, hier
diesen String, das ist immer die Version,
beziehungsweise die Version Range, und das habe ich dann einfach
dem Semware Create, was bei Cargo auch
verwendet wird, in die Hand gedrückt und habe gesagt,
hier, passt das mal, bis ich dann halt dort gesehen habe,
nee, die machen Sachen, die gehen in
Rust-Semware so nicht. Zum Beispiel
kleiner gleich
2.0.0, kleiner
3. Kannst du einfach schreiben.
Und das ist alles
ein bisschen eklig.
Ja, mittlerweile
passt das, aber ich bin halt dem tatsächlichen
Package-JSON und
Yarn-Log evaluieren,
noch kein Schritt weiter gekommen, weil ich
das letzte Mal vor einer Woche dran arbeiten konnte.
Aber wir hören tatsächlich was, ich meine, du musst ja nicht den ganzen
Package-Manager schreiben, aber zumindest die
Manifest-Datei auswerten und
da sicher
rauszudampfen, was da eigentlich drinsteht
und zu verifizieren, dass es auch
legal, also valide Syntax
ist, die da drinsteht. Mein Ziel war, dass ich
zumindest die Version auflösen kann und dann
aus einer
die Sachen auch runterladen kann, beziehungsweise
aus dem Jarncache die Sachen installieren kann.
Sehr großartig.
So, das ist allerdings...
Gerade das rekursive
Auflösen wird dann wahrscheinlich die größte
Schwierigkeit. Da ist, glaube ich, noch ein bisschen
Graflogik noch drin, die
ich noch mal ein bisschen
researchen muss. Also ich hatte gehofft, dass ich vielleicht einfach ein bisschen
Logik aus anderen Packetmanagern re-usen
könnte, aber ich habe da noch nicht weiter dran gearbeitet,
dass ich da jetzt erzählen kann. Es gibt so eine
Kamera mit in die Schornos hauen
von dem Justin
Spar Summers, shit.
Das ist komischer Name.
Es gibt von dem Justin Spar Summers
heißt der, der hat an
Carthage mitgearbeitet, diesem
I'm iOS Package Manager oder
I'm Coco Package Manager.
Der arbeitet, wenn ich mich nicht alles täusche, bei Facebook.
Hat mal bei GitHub gearbeitet und so war das da.
Genau, genau, ja.
Der hat mal eine C++
Library namens Arbiter geschrieben.
Die hau ich mal mit in die Shownotes.
Das ist eine, meinte er, ich hab's mir
nicht genauer angeschaut, um ehrlich zu sein,
eine Dependency Manager Library,
mit der du
Dependency Manager schreiben kannst,
aufbauen auf diese Library, die dir vieles von dem Heavy Lifting
abnimmt. Das ist mal interessant
zum Anschauen, was das eigentlich unterstützt
und was der mit kann. Ich lese bloß grob,
der macht irgendwie
Compliant with Semantic Versioning, steht ja schon mit drin,
Lazy Decentralized
Dependency Resolution, Paralyzable
Dependency Installation und vieles,
was dir das schon abnimmt. Es wäre ja ganz cool,
mal zu schauen, was das macht. Das letzte
zwar vor mehr als einem Jahr, aber
interessant. Ich fand es mal cool, wie ich für eine
Weile mal drüber gestolpert habe.
Hat gleich mal einen Stern auf GitHub von mir gekriegt.
Nice.
Apropos Stars auf GitHub, da ist
jetzt eine witzige Geschichte passiert.
Es gibt ja,
wie nennt man das?
Rockstar Developers?
Es gibt ja Leute, die allein durch ihre
Präsenz auf GitHub irgendwie bekannt
sind. Also Leute, die
berühmte Libraries geschrieben haben
oder an bestimmten Projekten mitarbeiten.
Also diese großen JavaScript-krassen Typen.
Die haben dann meistens, genauso wie auf Twitter oder auf anderen Social Networks,
das ist ja GitHub-Auchbusse und Social Network,
haben die halt eine große Follower-Chip von Leuten.
Und das hat witzige Side-Effects.
Ich habe jetzt vor ein paar Tagen einen Pull-Request von Steve Klappnick gekriegt.
Und Steve Klappnick hat natürlich tonnenweise Follower,
weil er sehr aktiv in der Rust-Welt ist.
Und er hat eigentlich bei mir auf einem Crate von mir,
ich weiß nicht, wie er darauf gestoßen ist,
ein Pull-Request gestellt, wo einfach
den Link zur Dokumentation geupdatet hat.
Das war echt ganz, ganz wenig. Vielleicht hat er sich
mal fünf Minuten angeguckt.
Ich hatte über Nacht
17 neue Stars auf dem Teil.
Das ist doch großartig.
Da dachte ich mir, ah, der Starter ist der Starter. Wir haben dir das alle gefunden.
Und dann guckst du halt auf Steve Klebniks Seite
und der hat halt in seiner Aktivitäts-
History, beziehungsweise wenn du ihm folgst,
dann siehst du halt Steve Klebnik just forked
this and this und dann steht bei ihm halt
in seiner Aktivitätsliste
und dann kriegst du halt so ein paar Sterne ab.
Also sie ziehen wie so eine
Fee, so Fairy Dust hinter sich
an GitHub-Stars.
So ein Gift von Steve Klepnik, wie er wie so ein Neon Cat
durchs All wandert und dahinter so GitHub-Stars.
Sehr schön.
Wenn einer von euch malen kann, dann macht doch mal bitte sowas.
Dann würde ich bestimmt freuen.
Es ist ja nicht so, als ob es nicht schöne genochen Mames mit Steve Klepnik gibt.
Das habe ich aber auch mal gehabt. Ich habe mal eine Swift-Library
geschrieben, diesen CLI-Spinner
und auf Twitter geschmissen.
Das war halt ein Swift-Klon von der
JavaScript-Library von dem Sindre Soros.
Und der Sindre ist halt auch so ein JavaScript
in Anführungszeichen Gott,
möchte ich mal sagen.
Und der hat das halt retweetet gehabt und zack,
da rieselte es GitHub-Stars.
Das war nicht super witzig.
Ich nenne sowas auch Starburst.
Aha, stimmt, da gibt es einen Begriff.
Also ich habe das letztes in einer Folge
von uns so genannt, das ist ein GitHub-Starburst.
Das kenne ich von dir, ja.
Wenn irgendwas geslashed oder
beziehungsweise mittlerweile gehackernuesed wird,
dann kriegt es ein GitHub-Starburst.
Süß. Den finde ich schön.
Aber das ist doch geil. Du hast aber auch
die Library für Notifications
mittlerweile, wie ich das verstanden habe.
Wenn du irgendwas in Rust machen willst, was irgendwie
Notifications auf den Desktop schickt, dann ist
der Weg unweigerlich zu Notify Rust.
Ich ärgere mich immer noch darüber, dass ich dem diesen
bescheuerten Namen gegeben habe, weil ja
Dash Rust im Namen
irgendwie auch keine gute Idee ist, aber
jetzt ist deine Chance, es umzubenennen auf sowas
sinnvolles wie Pivik. Der Name ist frei geworden.
Erzähl.
Pivik heißt nicht umbenannt. Pivik heißt jetzt
Matomo.
Echt?
Matomo, wie man es ausbringt.
Aber ist das nicht so ein Chat-Dings?
Pivik? Nee, Pivik ist dieser...
Nee, Metamore.
Nicht Metamost.
Metamost ist der Slack-Klon von GitLab.
Nee, nicht GitLab.
Egal, es spielt keine Rolle.
Nee, das war HipChat.
Nein, HipChat ist von den Atlassian-Leuten.
Oh Gott, es gibt echt zu viele von diesen Dingen.
Jedenfalls heißt Pivik jetzt Matomo.
Was ist denn das für ein Name?
Das ist sehr japanisch für
irgendwas ehrwürdig. Ich hab's vergessen.
Spiel keine Rolle. Ich find's
interessant.
Piwik ist bekannt. Jeder weiß,
wie das heißt. Warum nennt man sich dann um? Ich weiß
nicht. Sollen Sie es machen?
Jetzt heißen sie Matomo.
Wenn ich jetzt auf piwik.com gehe?
Aber wie gesagt, der Name ist frei. Du kannst deine Library umbenennen auf Piwik.
Nein.
Ungooglable.
Ah, ich soll nicht.
Oh Mann.
Nee, apropos random Dinge, die so passieren.
Ich habe...
Wunderbar.
Ich habe letztens...
Ich habe mir so eine App Parken.dd mal geschrieben,
zusammen mit dem Johannes, der die Android-Variante geschrieben hat.
Ich habe die iOS-Variante.
Wir haben zusammen so ein Backend dafür geschrieben,
dass die halt freie Parkplätze in diversen europäischen Städten anzeigt.
Mittlerweile sogar diverse dänische Städte mit drin.
Finde ich witzig, wie das einfach so community-witzig weiß.
Irgendein Publikum ist das da rein und Dinge.
Und ich habe letztens ein Google-Lerd bekommen.
Also ich habe so ein Google-Lerd auf Parken.dd,
weil ich das einfach mal mitkriegen will,
wenn da irgendwas passiert. Und da kam
ein Alert von wegen
so einer Seite, wie hieß die?
Steamed, da gab es irgendwie
zwei Netzwerke und das ist jetzt
auf utopian.io
und wir gerne in die Show-Notes mit rein.
So drei Plattformen, die irgendwie miteinander verknüpfen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung wie. Und da gibt es
einfach Leute, mittlerweile eins, zwei,
drei, vier, fünf, sechs, sechs Leute,
die einfach random sich mal dazu entschieden
haben, neue Icons für unsere App zu
designen. Und da sind echt krasse
Teile dabei. Und wir haben da halt voll die Vorschläge
und dann beweihräuchern die sich gegenseitig,
indem die sich irgendwie von Steam mit,
so wie ich das bekommen habe,
da gegenseitig Geld hin und her schicken.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie die auf dieses Projekt gestoßen sind.
Ich hätte es nicht mehr mitbekommen,
hätte ich nicht diesen Google Alert.
Die machen so Icon-Entwürfe,
schmeißen die auf diese Plattform,
schicken sich gegenseitig Geld hin und her.
Was ist das? Warum machen die das?
Das ist super schick.
Das ist nicht nur ein Icon, das irgendwie gemalt ist.
Teilweise sind das richtige Design-Studien,
wo sie so überlegt haben,
wir haben hier diese Initials P, D, D.
Wir haben auch noch als Eingang
dieses klassische Location-Pin-Symbol.
Und das ist hier meine visuelle Sprache,
die ich kombiniere.
Ich habe hier nach Golden Ratio
diese Circle, die ich miteinander kombiniere.
Da stecken echt Gedanken drin.
Und das ist die Schriftart, die ich verwende.
Und das ist die Color Palette.
Dieses eine, was ein animiertes Icon ist.
Genau, das habe ich auch verhofft, ja.
Ich finde es schon super fancy,
aber wo kommt die Motivation?
Stell dir vor, du bist
kein Hacker, der sich langweilt
und sich fragt, was er mal wieder hacken könnte,
sondern du bist Graphic Designer, der sich überlegt,
ich möchte jetzt mal für irgendwas.
Aber wie kommen die auf unser Projekt?
Ihr habt halt doch kein Logo.
Die Apps haben alle ein Icon, aber
ich meine,
ich weiß auch nicht, wo wir kommunizieren,
wenn dann meistens auf
Open Knowledge Foundation Slack,
aber
wir haben nichts davon mitbekommen,
einfach aus dem Nichts heraus,
gibt es da irgendwo eine Webseite,
wo Leute, anscheinend nicht nur einer,
sondern mehrere, einfach, hey, Parken-Idee,
witziges Projekt, wir designen jetzt mal dafür
eine Reihe von Icons.
Und so sexy hier
auf einem nassen iPhone
von der Seite als Mocker,
ich link das eine, weil ich
tatsächlich am krassesten finde, mal mit in die.
Also wo das animiert über dieser schrägen Karte schwebt,
ist echt schick, aber zum Beispiel das,
wo sie das P mit irgendeinem Auto
kombinieren, sieht schon ganz dämlich aus.
Ich meine, ich will die jetzt nicht unbedingt
runter machen, vielen Dank dafür, dass sie es machen,
aber ich hätte es ja auch nicht mitbekommen.
Wie geht das jetzt eigentlich?
Du hast ja jetzt nicht automatisch die Rechte da dran.
Nee, überhaupt nicht.
Wenn du das jetzt tatsächlich für deine App verwenden würdest,
dieses Logo, ich meine, die verwenden
deinen Namen, deinen Brandnamen
als Input für ihre Designs, aber
die haben ja nicht automatisch, ich weiß nicht,
wie das jetzt hier legal geht.
Keine Ahnung, also der eine mit diesem, tatsächlich mit diesem
Auto, wo ein P und ein D drinsteht,
der hat mir dann auch einen Pull Request geschickt,
wo er einfach das Icon in der App geupdatet hat.
Den Pull Request habe ich dann mal nicht angenommen.
Ich habe mich bedankt dafür.
Die schicken sich, wie gesagt, halt
Cryptocurrency durch die Gegend.
Ich verstehe diese Plattform nicht. Ich habe irgendwo
letztens gehört, steemit.com
soll das neue soziale Netzwerk sein. Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Da gibt es auch noch irgendwie so eine...
Du bist jetzt über 25, deswegen kriegst du so etwas.
Ja, bin ich jetzt alt? Ich verstehe
das nicht mehr.
Da gibt es auch irgendwie so eine Videoplattform.
DTube heißt das Ganze.
Irgendwelche Decentralized
Krams um...
Irgendwie...
Ich verstehe nichts davon.
Ich verstehe, was eine Cryptocurrency ist.
Ich verstehe Peer-to-Peer-Netz-Sachen.
Klar, aber ich verstehe diese Plattform nicht.
Ich verstehe nicht, was die da machen.
Ich verstehe nicht, was die Apps sind oder DApps,
irgendwie Decentralized Web Applications.
Das ist eigentlich das Thema, was ich das letzte Mal...
Kein blassen Schimmer.
Das ist eigentlich das Thema,
was ich das letzte Mal für diese Sendung vorschlagen wollte,
das Web 3.0.
Baut das alles auf Ethereum auf oder was?
Nee, aber die Idee ist, dass du zwar weiterhin soziale...
Also das Feature von Web 2.0, was es ausgemacht hat,
das sind halt soziale Netzwerke.
Echt?
Dass der Content eigentlich von den Usern produziert wird.
Achso, okay.
Dass du wesentlich interaktiver bist.
Und ich glaube, der Hintergedanke von dem Begriff Web 3.0,
der eigentlich schon zehn Jahre alt ist,
aber mittlerweile mit einer Bedeutung gefüllt wird,
ist, dass man jetzt mehr und mehr von diesen zentralisierten Netzwerken
hin zu dezentralisierten Sachen übergeht.
Das fängt mit Cryptocurrencies an.
Sachen wie
Schneid mich raus.
Wie heißt denn dieses
mit dem
Twitter-Klon?
Tut.
Sachen wie Mastodon zum Beispiel,
wo Leute
dezentralisiert
Sachen wie Mastodon zum Beispiel,
wo du plötzlich ein dezentralisiertes
soziales Netzwerk hast. Das hat ja mit
Diaspora schon angefangen.
Aber jetzt geben die Leute dem plötzlichen Namen
und weisen dem wesentlich mehr Bedeutung zu.
How Web 3.0
will work. Also du musst bloß mal nach
Web 3.0.
Ich glaube, wenn du in die
Wie heißt diese Grafik?
Google Zeitgeist, wo du siehst,
wie viele Suchergebnisse
oder wie viele suchen ein bestimmter Begriff
Gib mal Industrie 4.0 ein.
Und Industrie 5.0.
Das ist alles solche Bullshit-Begriffe.
Ich habe den Eindruck, das ist ein Begriff, der momentan spiked.
Deswegen hatte ich das mal ganz kurz als Thema vorgeschlagen.
Aber vielleicht ist es zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo wir diese Folge aufnehmen, auch schon wieder vorbei.
Sind wir schon bei Peak Web 3.0?
Ich verstehe das alles nicht.
Ich glaube, wir haben gerade einen Sendungstitel.
Peak Web 3.0, finde ich gut.
Oh Mann.
Ja, ich glaube, damit haben wir jetzt auch genug über Web 3.0 gesagt.
Lass dich abhaken.
Wenn sich jemand von euch da draußen intensiver damit beschäftigt,
vielleicht an einer Web3.0
Plattform mitarbeitet.
Das widerspricht ja so ein bisschen
dem Konzept, aber wenn sich jemand da draußen
von euch ein bisschen besser damit auskennt, wir haben
auch, wie gesagt, immer gerne Gäste in unserem Podcast.
Nochmal ganz kurz
Backpedaling, weil ich gerade den
Sindre vorher abgesprochen hatte.
Ich hatte letztens auch so ein schönes Gist gefunden
auf GitHub.
Bist du einer von den Leuten, die Gist
sagen? Ich sag nicht Gist,
es ist ein Git.
Ich mache mir Spaß, das heißt wirklich Gist.
Es ist nicht wie GIF.
GIF, Mann.
Aber GIST ist ja tatsächlich auch ein englisches Wort,
du nicht mit G.
Nee, doch, klar mit G.
Ja, klar mit G.
Ich bin mir selber fertig hier.
Zurück.
Du hast also ein schönes GIST.
Ich habe ein schönes GIST gefunden.
Jetzt sage ich immer nur GIST.
Nein!
Ich habe ein schönes GIST gefunden.
Die Top 1000 NPM Packages
und die Most Dependencies.
Und damals auf Platz 1, jetzt nicht mehr,
ist sindresorhus.j
Es ist einfach ein Package,
was den Namen von Sintra hat,
aber einfach halt alle seine Packages
included, dass du in einem Package
alle Sintra-Packages inkluden kannst.
Total nutzloses Package.
Hat 780 Dependencies.
Braucht 2,3...
Also Dependence meinst du das, ne?
Nee.
Das zieht als Dependencies
alle von Sintra-Packages rein.
Ach so, ach zu Scheiße.
Braucht 2,3 Gigabyte Disk Space.
Braucht ungefähr 6 Minuten mit
MbM installiert zu werden.
ist das kaputt.
Aber die, krass, generell die Liste
der Packages mit den
Most Dependencies ist ein bisschen beängstigend.
Also mit 770 Packages führst du da an.
Als erstes Package ist das, was glaube ich
was richtiges ist. Da gibt es ein Package, das heißt
3.0.0. Da gibt es so
komische... Auf Platz 0
ist No One Left Behind.
Ich glaube, das ist ein
Spaß-Package. Wie häufig wird denn das aktualisiert?
25. Februar ist tatsächlich...
Das hat exakt 1000 Dependencies.
Mittlerweile versuchen Leute, das offenbar zu hijacken.
Hier gibt es halt auch
in Anführungsstrichen sinnvolle
Packages relativ weit oben.
Die haben halt Hunderte
von Dependencies.
Also Packages, die wirklich
ernsthaft versuchen, ihren Job zu machen.
Hunderte. Holy Fug.
Das ist halt nicht rekursiv betrachtet,
sondern nur Top-Level-Dependencies.
Also rekursiv gehst du da ja
weit, weit, weit tief weiter in Node.
Sicher?
Okay, jetzt weiß ich es nicht mehr.
Weil
rekursiv ein paar hundert Dependencies
kriegst du schnell.
Das ist relativ schnell.
Also Top Packages with Most Dependencies,
also die selber viele andere benutzen,
da muss ich jetzt echt mal von oben nach unten
lesen, bis ich da überhaupt mal was finde, was sinnvoll ist.
Ja, das sind ja gar nicht mehr, also gerade die
Nummer 3 geht ja schon los.
PB Schema.
Das ist ein FHIR 2.
Und wo ist da die...
Ach nee, es hat 51 Dependencies.
Ha, hast recht.
Und das ist rekursiv betrachtet.
Never mind.
This project was generated with Angular CLI.
Das ist...
Irgendwas.
Das ist doch irgendeine Web-Anwendung.
React Input Select.
Wir müssen aber jetzt hier wahrscheinlich nicht durchgehen.
Ich hau den Link mal mit.
Vielleicht können wir das ja noch mal ein bisschen runter.
Aber da kommt echt eine ganze Menge Zeug.
Was wurde...
bei den Sachen, die natürlich
tausend und mehrere,
die top tausend NPM-Packages,
die Dependents haben,
das ist natürlich alles sinnvolles Zeug.
Hier, Lodash, Request, Jog, A7, Commander,
genau, Bluebird,
Leftpad,
Leftpad?
Nee, aber das ist nicht mehr.
Leftpad, Platz 784.
Gerade nicht mal so populär,
dieses Leftpad.
Oh Mann.
Ja, also wenn
ihr eure Pakete hier in dieser Liste
haben möchtet, möglichst in der ersten Liste,
dann müsst ihr noch mal
auf Hacker News ein bisschen auf der Startseite
eine Weile rumhängen.
JSON-Schema,
BigNumberJS.
Ich kann mal was rausschneiden
von dem Gespräch gerade.
Ja, cool.
Nee, das nur noch mal kurz als Einwurf.
Ich fand es bloß witzig, dass das
Sintressortus.js existiert.
Das ist auch nötig.
Oh Mann.
Naja, das ist einfach so ein Prelude,
da musst du nicht, dann denkst du ja auch,
ich mag alles von dem.
Aber habe ich einfach alles,
alles, was du jemals gebrauchen könntest.
Ist ja nicht so, als ob es nicht übelst leicht ist,
mal eben selber schnell was, was du genau brauchst,
mit reinzutun.
Ja, manche Leute haben halt wirklich diese Library
mit diversen kleinen, irgendwelchen Helpern,
die sich halt in ihre Projekte immer reinziehen.
Finde ich zwar auch komisch,
weil ich versuche immer mir anzueignen,
sowas nicht zu machen,
weil dann dependest du ganz schnell auf sowas
und betrachtest du gar nicht.
ziehst du ziemlich schnell Lodash erstmal ein.
Ja klar und
wie heißt das, dieses eine Frontend-Java-Scripting, was immer
dabei ist von drei verschiedenen, jQuery,
jQuery ziehst du halt von drei verschiedenen CDNs
in jede Webseite mit rein.
Aber jQuery ist ja mittlerweile, brauchst du auch fast nicht mehr.
Du brauchst es halt auch nicht, das betrifft
vieles von den Sachen.
Wenn du halt zum Beispiel nicht lernst, wie man mit
Networking-APIs umgeht und du immer irgendwelche
Helper-Libraries reinziehst, die das abstrahieren,
dann weißt du auch nicht, wie man es richtig macht und dann hast du
immer irgendwelche Bugs und irgendwelche
keine Ahnung, irgendwelche Abstraktionen,
kommst du nicht klar oder nutzt halt irgendwelche
komischen anderen Dinge und du verstehst halt manche
Dinge einfach nicht. An dieser Stelle
ein kurzer Tipp, ihr kennt es wahrscheinlich schon,
aber es gibt die Webseite youmightnotneedjQuery.com
Kann ich nicht.
Da ist einfach eine schöne, du scrollst
hier runter, da hast du schöne Gegenüberstellungen für
AJAX, Post Requests, Requests,
Effekte, Fade-in-Hide,
Show, du hast dann immer
Links, wie du es mit jQuery machen würdest, das ist dann
ein Einzeiler, oder auf der
rechten Seite, wie du es mit purem JavaScript mit modernen
Browser-APIs machen würdest, was dann vielleicht manchmal so
10, 15 Zeilen lang ist, oder
im Fall vom Post-Request ist es sogar
kürzer als der J-Regular.
Okay, das ist ungebrochen hier, aber
und da steht
ja drin, ab welchem Browser das geht. Das ist häufig
ein IE, weil es mit
Firefox und
Chrome und Safari wahrscheinlich schon wesentlich länger geht.
Aber zum Beispiel, das ist der klassische
CSS-Selector-Code,
wo du sagst,
hol mir mal ein Objekt aus dem DOM,
was diesem CSS-Selektor entspricht
oder alle, die diesem Selektor,
alles, was diese Klasse hat
und unter Objekte davon oder alle
TRs aus der Table,
was man mit jQuery am häufigsten
macht und das ist einfach was, was
in den modernen
Browser-APIs einfach mittlerweile drin ist.
Also DOM-Query-Select,
wie auch immer, ich weiß nicht genau, wie die Methode heißt.
Dementsprechend
jQuery braucht man tatsächlich wirklich fast.
Ja, aber das war auch nur so eine Sache, was jeder
überall included hat. Meine Hoffnung
ist, dass man in JavaScript demnächst auch
sowas wie Lodash nicht mehr braucht,
weil ein paar funktionale Features
in die Sprache mittlerweile reinwandern.
Warum braucht man überhaupt Lodash? Was macht das?
Ich mache kein Frontend.js, ich kenne mich da überhaupt
nicht aus. Für Frontend brauchst du es auch überhaupt nicht.
Ich habe zum Beispiel einen Code Generator in JavaScript
geschrieben, haben wir auch relativ viel Lodash verwendet.
Da hast du einfach Sachen drin wie...
Helper Functions ist jetzt ganz viel oder was?
Jetzt schaue ich mal rein.
Ich habe ja vorhin definiert, was
Functional Programming ist.
Du hast...
minimale, oder beziehungsweise
wie man funktionale, was funktionale Features
einer Sprache sind und was man damit machen kann.
Du kannst zum Beispiel über eine Menge drüber iterieren
und diesen Iterator,
zum Beispiel
hast du deinen Vektor oder deine
Hashmap und dann sagst du iter, hast du einen Iterator
drüber, das ist einfach ein Objekt, was dir immer ein nächstes gibt.
Und das, da hängst
du dann entweder einen Filter und dann ein Collect
dran, um das dann in eine neue
Collection umzuwandeln,
oder du chanest an diesem Iterator
andere Iterator-Adapter
dran. Das heißt, du hast so aus einem,
dass du ein Map dranhängst, womit du das umwandelst,
dann hängst du ein Filter dran, da kommt einfach ein neuer
Iterator raus und dann hast du
quasi, wenn ich sage Map, Filter, Collect,
kollekte ich aus einem
Filter
von einem Map
von einem Vektor-Iterator.
Die werden dann erst,
die werden im Typsystem, hast du manchmal,
wenn du Fehler hast und ganz viele hintereinander gechained hast,
dann hast du einen ziemlich komplexen Typen,
aber die werden dann zusammengeschmissen und dann
lazy evaluiert. Das heißt,
dass ich nicht erst über alles drüber
iteriere, dann über alles drüber mappe,
dann mir einen neuen Array daraus
zusammengebaut habe, über den ich dann
nochmal filtere und das immer wieder mache
und immer wieder drüber renne, das wäre eager.
Sondern ich habe einen Iterator,
der alles in einem Schritt macht. Und wenn
ich hinten dran noch schreibe
take five oder take one, dann nehme ich auch
erst bloß die ersten fünf Ergebnisse daraus. Und mehr macht
das Ding wirklich nicht.
Das geht in JavaScript so nicht. Du kannst
zwar auf einem Array sagen,
for each oder map
und dann filter und dann nochmal map,
aber das ist dann egal. Jedes Mal, wenn ich
map sage, kommt hinterher sofort ein neues
Array raus, auf dem ich dann wieder Filter
aufrufen kann. Auf dem kommt dann ein neues,
da gibt es kein Zwischenobjekt. Du musst darauf auch nicht
fold oder collect sagen, sondern du hast
immer sofort ein Ergebnis und das macht es halt
inperformant. Und die lazy Sachen kommen dann mit
Lodash mit rein oder was? Lodash bringt ein paar von solchen Sachen
mit, die sind leider auch nicht lazy, aber die bringen halt noch
mehr Sachen mit, die
ich wollte gerade mal reingucken,
Da kannst du zum Beispiel Schnittmengen
kannst du machen.
Du hast eine Funktion, da gibst du
eine Liste von Sachen rein und eine Liste von anderen Sachen rein
und kannst dir die Schnittmenge von
diesen beiden Listen geben lassen. Das sind Sachen,
die in JavaScript
direkt so noch nicht gehen.
Du kannst das sortieren
nach, du kannst
aus Objekten Sachen rausholen, die
bringen aber auch ein bisschen sogenannte Polyfills
für Features mit, die JavaScript leider noch nicht hat
oder noch nicht hatte. Zum Beispiel, dass ich
über Objekte drüber iterieren kann, wie über eine Hashmap.
Das ging,
du kannst, du hast ja in JavaScript
alles ein Objekt mit Key-Value-Paaren,
aber du konntest in JavaScript bis
vor sehr kurzer Zeit noch nicht einfach drüber
iterieren und sagen, gib mir mal alle Key-Value-Paare
daraus aus diesem Objekt. Das geht erst
mit Object-Entries seit
ECMAScript 2015
oder 2016, also erst seit kurzem.
Und das ist längst noch nicht überall da. Und das sind solche Sachen,
die in Lodash zum Beispiel mit drin sind.
Oder Flat-Mapping.
Es gibt eine andere
Also es ist eine Art erweiterte Standard-Lib.
Ja, klar, weil JavaScript keine sinnvolle Standard-Lib hat.
Das kommt alles mit der Zeit erst.
Und das ist eine Sache, die mir zum Beispiel aufgefallen ist.
Es gibt Iteratoren in JavaScript.
Du kannst dir aus einem Array einen Iterator rausholen.
Das ist ein Objekt, auf den du immer wieder Next aufrufen kannst.
Das hat einen internen Counter und es gibt dir immer das nächste Objekt daraus.
Aber damit kannst du eigentlich nichts machen.
Wenn du darüber filtern oder mappen möchtest,
dann musst du das erst wieder in einen anderen Array rein kollekten,
weil ein Iterator keine Filter- oder Map-Methoden mitbringen.
Das ist eigentlich relativ nutzlos.
Ich frage mich immer, was man mit so einem
Iterator in JavaScript machen soll.
Dafür gibt es LazyJS,
das ist zum Beispiel ein Ansatz, wo
oder
ein paar andere Libraries,
wie hieß denn das, RAM?
Ach, ich habe es mir nicht genau
gemerkt. Es gibt noch ein paar
Competitor
to Lodash oder Underscore,
die teilweise auch LazyIteration
mitbringen, aber das ist
leider in der Sprache fehlt es noch vollständig.
dafür, dass man eigentlich relativ viel Functional Programming
mit JavaScript machen möchte, weil sie sich aufgrund
der Sprachfeatures
relativ schön dafür eignet, gerade
mit dieser sehr simplen
Lambda-Syntax, die sie
haben und das
Reference-Counting, dann macht es einfach super einfach,
irgendwelche gecurrylten Objekte
daraus zu machen. Currying ist in JavaScript super
schick und einfach. Du kannst
witzigerweise in JavaScript, genauso wie es
in Haskell aussehen würde, einfach hinschreiben,
const add ist gleich
und dann schreibst du in
a
file b file c
und dann schreibst du
a plus b plus c und das ist eine
gecurryte Funktion, wo du beliebig viele Parameter
reingeben kannst und dann immer wieder eine Funktion rauskriegst,
die den Rest macht. Das ist schön. Das geht in JavaScript
jetzt schon. Wirklich das Currying, genau,
wie man es kennt und nicht nur
das partial application.
Genau, partial application. Und dann schaust du dir aber die
Iteratoren aus dieser Sprache an und denkst dir, was soll ich denn damit?
Deswegen ist sowas wie
Leute, ist noch interessant. Verstehe.
Okay. Hat er also eine
Darant-Berechtigung irgendwo. Genau.
Naja, wie gesagt,
ich hoffe ja, dass das mehr und mehr in diese Sprache
jetzt reinwandert. Die machen ja mittlerweile auch wieder relativ
große Schritte, genauso wie C++ plötzlich angefangen
hat festzustellen, die Leute
wollen ja heute nicht genau das gleiche
mit der Programmiersprache machen wie vor 20 Jahren.
Da sollten wir also vielleicht mal ein paar neue Features hinzufügen.
Ja, aber halt nur größer wachsen.
Also du sollst auch immer noch schön das machen können, wie du es vor 20
Jahren gemacht hast. Also C++
soll ja das, wie du schon mal
beschrieben hast, das Monstrum sein, was
alle Features von allen Sprachen hat,
auf eine andere Art und Weise.
In JavaScript hat man jetzt zum Beispiel nicht nur,
dass man Klassen hinzugefügt hat zu der Sprache
in ES
2015.
Mittlerweile in der
nächsten Iteration gibt es auch
Private Members.
In JavaScript?
Das sind dann Members, die mit
und das Geilste ist die Syntax.
Die fangen mit Raute an.
Was? Okay.
Also du kannst Members haben, die mit Router anfangen
oder Router. Ich habe mir die so lange nicht genau
gemerkt. Und die sind
von außen nicht einsehbar.
Da fand ich ja den Python-Weg auch immer geil.
Ja, wir haben natürlich Support für private Member.
Du musst einfach mit dem Underscore prefixen.
Ja, und dann heißt die einfach
anders. Ja klar, du kannst trotzdem daraus zugreifen. Ach so,
wie machen wir dann wirklich privat? Ja, einfach zwei Unterstriche.
Ach so, kannst du trotzdem daraus zugreifen? Ja klar, kannst du
trotzdem daraus zugreifen.
Was ist dann wirklich privat?
Drei Unterstriche? In Python 3 geht das
tatsächlich nie mehr. Da kommst du nicht einfach an,
in Anführungsstrichen private Memoran, also die, die mit einem
Underscore anfangen, finde ich auch witzig.
Oder Go macht das ja auch, sagen wir mal, ähnlich,
indem du Dinge, die public sind, groß schreibst
und Dinge, die private sind, klein schreibst.
Bin ich auch eine witzige Art,
so typisch Go.
Eine ganz komische Konvention neu schaffen, aber
ey, immerhin habt ihr da was.
Nee, nicht drüber nachdenken.
Wie gesagt, Python
macht, wie gesagt, mittlerweile respektiert
das ja, was ich auch super cool finde. Ich habe in den letzten Tagen wieder
viel mit Python geschrieben. Ach, kann ich mir gucken.
Ich kann mal erzählen, was. Aber
erstmal zu Python selber.
Python 3 hat Typ-Annotationen.
Ja, schön, das hast du gezeigt.
Für mich erst mit neu entdeckt. Du kannst Python 3
quasi in alles Typen ranschreiben. Also es sind erstmal
korrekte Syntaxe. Ich glaube nicht, die werden
an manchen Stellen noch nicht betrachtet.
Das sehe ich mir genau das. Also zum Beispiel, wenn du eine Funktion
schreibst und du nimmst einen Parameter,
fuhr, war es ja bisher immer so,
Funktion, bla bla,
Funktion bar in Klammern foo und das ist jetzt
Python-Syntax für, du hast eine Funktion bar mit einem
Parameter, der heißt foo. Und da kannst du halt alles
reingeben. Genau. Und in Python
ab 3 kannst du auch hinschreiben foo-str.
Das ist jetzt ein String.
Und wenn du dann die Funktion aufrufst und du gibst dir
was anderes als ein String, dann kriegst du zur Runtime tatsächlich
von Python 3 ein Error hingeworfen,
eine Exception hingeworfen. Du versuchst hier gerade
in diese Funktion, die offensichtlich nur ein String
nimmt, in den Integer reinzugeben. Und das finde ich
echt nice, dass du so
halbwegs typisiertes Python hast.
Python hat ja seine Typen irgendwo intern.
Die sind halt immer schon schön versteckt und schön dynamisch.
Was du auch machen kannst,
zum Beispiel, du kannst eine Funktion mit einem File,
quasi Swift-Syntax-mäßig,
einen Rückgabetypen auch mit angeben. Was gibt die zurück?
Das wird zwar von Python dann nicht verifiziert.
Das ist halt komplett egal, was da steht.
Aber zum Beispiel, wenn du eine PyCharm,
die Python IDE von Deadbrains nutzt,
dann nutzt die das, um zu verifizieren.
Einerseits, wenn du
einen Wert und Return Value
in der Funktion schreibst, zum Beispiel, du returnst den None,
aber du hast gesagt, die Funktion return ein String,
dann markiert er das und sagt dir, hey, ist das vielleicht nicht ganz
was du vor dem Regime hast, schreib doch mal oben bitte
String or none hin und dann weißt du auch,
das ist quasi ein optional String. Oder wenn du
halt einen Wert entgegennimmst aus der Funktion, dann
siehst du auch gleich, was für einen Typ das hast und du kriegst halt
schöne Autocompletion, weil die Typen klar definiert
und sauber sind. Also es ist schön, wenn du eine IDE
hast wie PyCharm,
die das für dich
in einem Compile-Step macht,
aber leider hat ja Python kein Compile-Step.
Prinzipiell ist das natürlich nicht klar.
Theoretisch könntest du das allerdings jetzt schon machen.
Ich würde gerade sagen, das ist eigentlich ein Problem,
dass die diese Syntax erlauben, aber das noch nicht
enforcen, weil dann schreibst du jetzt
Code, der dann in der nächsten Python-Version,
wenn sie es dann anschalten, dann plötzlich kaputt ist.
Vielleicht, wenn sie es dann hat, ja.
Obwohl du ja ohne weiteres in Python zu jeder Zeit
einen Runtime-Fehler schmeißen könntest, wenn du
prüfst, dass du gerade ein Objekt zurückgibst oder
Returns aus dieser Funktion, was nicht deiner
Annotation entspricht. Da gibt es auch eine Python-Library
enforce, heißt die, wenn du schon sagst, du wirst
superen-enforcen, die heißt enforce.
Und dann haust du dir an deine Python-Funktion
den Decorator Enforce Runtime Validation dran.
Und dann validiert er das Runtime.
Hat zwar sicherlich einen kleinen Performance-Impact,
weil das ja dann tatsächlich,
also was macht der Decorator?
Der rappt die einfach in eine andere Funktion,
die vorher verifiziert, dass die Typen passen.
Du kannst ja wahrscheinlich diesen Decorator,
je nachdem wie du es auslieferst,
durch was ersetzen, der eine No-Ob ist.
Ja, Python hat halt keine Debug-Build,
weil du keine Builds hast.
Aber du musst dann schauen,
ob irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
eine End war, ob Debug gesetzt ist.
Aber das Problem ist halt, die Decorator werden ja zur, in Anführungsstrichen, Compile-Time ausgeführt.
Also bevor du tatsächlich was machst, bevor der global irgendwie Code ausführt oder eine Main sucht,
executet der die Decorator und umwrappt deine Funktion dann in was auch immer, was dann dieser Decorator macht.
Und also müsstest du an den Stellen schon da irgendwie reinhaken.
Da gibt es bestimmt irgendwie eine Funktion, damit umzugehen.
Wahrscheinlich ist das so bei Enforce irgendwo dokumentiert.
Aber ich finde es cool, dass sowas existiert.
und das kann halt nur zur Runtime dann verifizieren,
aber das ist schon mal besser als gar nichts.
Ist es nicht sogar in Python so, dass du, wenn du einen Syntax-Fehler
in einer Funktion hast, dass der erst dann
auftritt, wenn du diese Funktion auch aufrufst?
Müsste ja quasi. Bin ich mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher.
Aber es ist eigentlich was, was dir schon
in der Parsing-Phase auffällt.
Aber Python ist ja halb kompiliert, oder?
Du hast ja irgendwo diese PyC-Code.
Ja, deswegen dachte ich, irgendjemand hat
mir nicht erzählt, dass der Syntax-Fehler
erst zur Compile-Zeit, erst auftreten,
wenn du in diese Funktion auch reinläufst.
Aber das kann ich mir eigentlich gar nicht so richtig vorstellen.
das müsste eigentlich das erste sein, was auch für
das ist ja schon ein gefährliches Halbwissen.
Brauchen wir mal einen Python-Guru, den wir hier befragen können
zu witzigen Dingen. Aber auf jeden Fall hatte ich sehr viel Spaß
mit Python die letzten Tage. Ich habe mir
nämlich ein paar Telegram-Bots geschrieben.
Ich habe da sehr viel Spaß gehabt,
als mir der Gedanke kam,
dass ich eigentlich
sehr viel Freude daran habe,
kleine CLIs zu schreiben.
Und CLIs lassen sich recht schön schreiben,
da muss man nicht ekelhaft einen UI-Code
schreiben. Die sind
einfach zu nutzen meist. Du hast ein paar
definierte Flags oder Dinge, die du reingibst,
Input, und die machen dann irgendwas
und das finde ich echt schick.
Und das mache ich gerne.
Das Problem ist bloß immer, wo lege ich die hin
und wie führe ich die aus und wie mache ich das
von verschiedenen Geräten?
Das geht natürlich überhaupt nicht dann, aber dass sie meistens dann irgendwo
auf dem Desktop rumliegen und dann kannst du damit was machen.
Und ja, ich bin auf den Dreh gekommen,
dass Chatbots eigentlich eine echt
geile Möglichkeit sind,
um sowas zu rappen.
Du hast, wenn du zum Beispiel,
jetzt mal mein Beispiel Telegram,
du hast Telegram-Clients auf allen Plattformen,
die dir quasi komplett die UI abnehmen
und du interfacest mit diesem Bot textbasiert,
das heißt, es ist quasi ähnlich wie der Input zu einem CLI-Command
und du kriegst Output zurück,
dann muss das Ding einfach irgendwo laufen,
auf einem Server irgendwo
und du hast auf allen Plattformen,
wo du diese Chat-Applikation auch mit hast,
hast du komplett gelöst zum einen UI
und zum anderen Notifications.
Wenn sich dein Bot irgendwie anschreiben möchte
und dir was schickt und du hast nur dein Mobilgerät in der Tasche,
dann kriegst du da tatsächlich auch einfach
die Notification geschickt. Das ist total cool.
Und du rappst einfach quasi
die CLI in einen Bot und
bist ja von überall zugänglich und du kannst damit
interagieren und machen, was du möchtest.
Das Schöne ist auch, du kannst auch Authentication damit sofort
lösen, weil der Bot kann ja verifizieren.
Du kannst ja in diesem Netzwerk nur unter diesem
Namen Nachrichten schicken, wenn du wirklich auch eingeloggt
bist. Das hat auch das Chatprogramm gelöst.
Und das ist witzigerweise wieder ein
Feature,
was Jabber schon vor 15
hatte. Das war,
du kannst bei
Jabber kannst du,
gibt es ein Protokoll, mit dem du Befehle
oder beziehungsweise mit dem in Service
ein bestimmtes Set an
Commands bereitstellen kannst.
Und so Clients wie Psy oder
G-Gym können dir auf bestimmten Clients,
so wurden zum Beispiel diese ganzen
Login-Masken für ICQ-Gateways
gemacht. Du hast
auf diesen Gateways, die liefen
halt als ICQ-Client für dich und die haben sich für dich
in ICQ eingeloggt und die haben dir dann
zur Verfügung gestellt, ein Set von Commands, wo du dein Passwort
und Benutzernamen eingeben kannst, wo du dich
deregistrieren konntest und so weiter und so fort.
Und das war eigentlich,
die haben wirklich ihr Interface
in einer wohldefinierten
XML-Struktur dargestellt und dein
Client hat dir da ein Formular draus gerendert,
wo du Haken anklicken konntest oder
Sachen eintragen konntest. Und da habe ich mir auch gedacht,
ach, das ist geil, das hätte ich gerne überall
und da möchte ich gerne irgendwelche
IoT-Geräte zum Beispiel mit fernsteuern können.
Die sind dann einfach als
Jabber-Teilnehmer oder als Jabber-Service
an irgendeinem Server angemeldet.
Die haben einen Status.
Du könntest dir dann quasi in deinem
Jabber-Roster,
hat ja mittlerweile fast keiner mehr,
könntest du dir den Status von unterschiedlichen Geräten angucken.
Die könnten teilweise noch
Child-Nodes haben, die du auf und zu klappen konntest.
Das ist in Jabber eigentlich komplett ausgedrückt.
Und dann kannst du darauf sagen, gib mir mal die Liste
an Commands, die ich ausführen kann. Die ist auch abhängig
davon, ob du bei dem Ding mit bestimmten
Rechten registriert bist. Es gibt Sachen,
die kann jeder ausführen. Es gibt Sachen,
die können nur bestimmte Benutzer, die dort angemeldet sind,
ausführen, weil du sagst einfach,
du schreibst das Ding an, sag mir mal, was ich bei dir machen kann
und das schaut halt nach, naja, du bist
doch gerade Hendrik, also ich gebe dir mal diese Liste von Sachen,
die du bei mir machen kannst.
Und dann macht dir dein Client,
macht dir einfach nativ so ein Formular auf,
wo du irgendwas ausführen kannst. Das ist quasi genau das,
was du gerade mit Telegram beschrieben hast. Das ging schon
vor Ewigkeiten mit Jabber und ich habe mir gedacht,
ah, schade, dass die ganzen Clients das alle nicht machen.
Und dann habe ich mir Jabber-Sachen angeguckt,
weil ich irgendwelche Sachen damit fernsteuern konnte.
Das freut mich auch wieder zu hören, dass Jabber alle Probleme,
die man heutzutage hat und neu löst, schon vor langer Zeit gelöst hat.
Aber leider so kompliziert versteckt in irgendwelchen XePs,
dass sie niemand wieder nutzen kann.
Ich kann immer wieder empfehlen, lest euch mal Jabber XePs durch.
Das ist teilweise sehr witzig.
Jabber ist so toll und ich würde so gerne Jabber für alles nutzen.
Ich nutze Jabber auch sehr aktiv, mit anderen Leuten zu schreiben.
Aber kein Client, den ich habe und kein Server, den ich nutze,
unterstützt alle XePs, die ich cool finde.
und das wäre echt schön, wenn es da einfach
was gäbe, was einfach alles Coole kann
und alle das nutzen würden, natürlich
wäre das toll, aber das ist halt leider
einfach nicht so. Ich habe neulich eine Notification bekommen,
dass eine neue Version von Psy rausgekommen
ist. Was ist Psy? Psy ist ein
cute geschriebener Jabber-Client,
den ich
früher, am Anfang des Studiums,
sehr intensiv genutzt habe,
als wir noch alle Jabber benutzt haben damals
und der ist dann eine Zeit lang
nicht maintained worden, dass dann immer so alle drei Jahre
mal neue Versionen rausgekommen, so Version
0.13, 0.14,
0.15 waren alle so anderthalb Jahre
auseinander. Version 0.15
ist, hier steht es auf der Startseite,
3. Oktober 2012 released worden.
Danach war das Projekt einigermaßen
tot. Die Leute, die daran gearbeitet
haben, haben dann gesagt,
naja, wir schreiben jetzt, das ist zu viel
hier alter, toter
Code, wir schreiben jetzt mal einen neuen Jabber-Client
und haben Swift geschrieben.
Ach, da kommt Swift her. Genau,
die Leute, die Swiften,
und die ganzen Java Libraries dazu gebaut haben.
Das sind die, die vorher Psy maintained haben.
Aber in der russischen Entwickler-Community
hat sich dann Psy Plus herauskristallisiert.
Das sind einfach Leute, die Patches dafür gesammelt haben.
Und das ist ein ziemlich beeindruckendes Set
an zusätzlichen Plugins dazu entstanden.
Da hat man einfach Psy Plus weiter benutzt.
Und Psy selber, der Mainline-Client,
ist immer weiter stale rumgelegen.
Und irgendwann hat man sich gedacht,
Gut, wir merchen das jetzt mal wieder zusammen.
Die nächste Version von Psy nach 0.15,
die 2012 rauskam, ist
Version 1.2.
Okay.
Die 2017 rauskam,
am 7. August.
Und jetzt vor kurzem,
warum habe ich das eigentlich vor kurzem?
Wahrscheinlich hat vor kurzem erst jemand das im
Arch Linux
Paketmanager eingetragen.
Die aktuellste Version ist
1.3 vom September 2017.
Da dachte ich mir, ach, eigentlich kann ich das mal
wieder anmachen. Da habe ich mir
Psy wieder installiert, da habe ich meinen Jabber-Client mal wieder
aktualisiert. Es sind auch immer noch die gleichen Leute
die ganze Zeit online. Und dann wollte ich
einen anschreiben und dann stelle ich fest, ah, jetzt weiß ich, warum
ich das Ding nicht mehr benutzt habe. Es hat keinen
Omemo-Support. Es gibt kein Omemo-Plugin.
Dann habe ich mir mit Gajim
installiert und dann habe ich festgestellt, ach, Gajim
kann genauso viel oder es ist auch
einer der umfangreichsten Jabber-Clients.
Das sieht hässlich aus.
Das ist echt das Problem. Es gibt keine guten Jabber-Client.
Es gibt gewisse Dinge, die willst du einfach haben.
Du musst dir auch ein Riesenset an Features abdecken.
Memo ist mittlerweile echt Pflicht,
aber das kann halt gefühlt keiner außer
Conversations und Gejim.
Was brauchen wir noch? Man will noch, dass
die Message of the History
gesinkt wird. Wie hieß das nochmal? Habe ich vergessen den Namen
dafür? Es gibt schon eine Reihe an XEPs, die sind echt
wichtig, aber... Es gibt auch ein paar XEPs,
also dieses Standard
kann ja mittlerweile auch Sachen, die
oder Features, die
es gibt auch ein paar Features,
die andere Chat-Clients eingeführt
haben, die dem dann ein bisschen den Rang abgelaufen haben.
Zum Beispiel, dass du jede Konversation zwischen
Leuten ohne weiteres zu einem
Multi-User-Chat, zu einem MOOC
upgraden konntest. Das konntest du bei Hangouts machen.
Also wir beide chatten hier, haben eine Session.
Und wenn wir jetzt plötzlich mit einem Tritt chatten wollten,
mussten wir in Jabba
umständlich unter diesem Conference Endpoint
dann irgendwie ein neues
Buch aufmachen. Es gibt
drei unterschiedliche Sorten von
Konversationen. Und der Astro, wenn er
das jetzt zufällig hören sollte, würde mich vielleicht korrigieren.
Aber es gab bei Jabba immer
einen Two-Person-Chat, einen ganz normalen Chat.
Dann gab es Messages.
da hast du auch direkt einfach eine Person
angeschrieben. Das hatte dann bei Psy sogar so ein bisschen
eine Maske, die ein bisschen wie E-Mail aussah.
Da konnte man, glaube ich, sogar Anhänge schicken.
Eigentlich könntest du mit
Jabber bereits vor
15 Jahren E-Mail ersetzen. Vollständig.
Some people would like to differ.
Und dann gibt es Muck.
Aber was du eigentlich haben möchtest, ist,
wie es in Slack geht,
dass du sagen kannst, ich habe eine Direct Message
zwischen zwei Leuten, ich kann aber ohne weiteres eine dritte Person
immer wieder zuholen. Ich glaube, bei Slack wird dann
auch eine neue Gruppe aufgemacht.
Du kannst nicht...
Aber ich meine,
dieser Workflow, na dann holen wir
halt noch jemanden mit dazu. Alles ist
erstmal per se ein Muck, selbst wenn es bloß zwischen
zwei Leuten ist. Das hat
Jabba nicht so gut abgebildet.
Ich glaube, da gibt es gerade der
Daniel Gulch,
der Conversations
entwickelt hat, selber sehr
intensiv Standardisierungsvorschläge
gemacht und XEPs geschrieben,
gerade auch für solche Features, weil er
Jabber in das 21. Jahrhundert
holen wollte, was diese Sachen angeht.
Ich würde so gerne Conversations auf jeder Plattformen haben.
Mein Jabber-Klein, meiner Wahl, ich gebe es ja ungern zu,
der kann nicht mal OTR.
Der kann nichts.
Du bist doch ein recht versierter iOS-Entwickler.
Habe ich das richtig verstanden?
Ja, nee, ja nicht, aber okay.
Portiere doch einfach mal so einen schönen Jabber-Klein.
Klar, ist ja kein Akt.
Gerade auf iOS gibt es ja ein paar, die sind alle scheiße,
aber das liegt auch ein bisschen daran, dass du halt
im Hintergrund nicht einfach für immer laufen kannst
als App ohne weiteres.
Das ist das Problem von den
mobilen Plattformen.
Du möchtest,
bei Jabba hast du Presence, das heißt, du bist die ganze
Zeit online, oder beziehungsweise
du strahlst deine Presence aus, was mittlerweile
auch nicht mehr wirklich
angemessen ist. Wir sind
einfach alle immer available.
Das ist nicht so, ich bin away from
meinem Computer oder sowas, oder ich bin
gerade nicht online oder sowas. Früher hast du Leute, die
im IRC online waren, gefingert und hast gesehen,
an welchem Rechner in der Uni die sitzen.
Genau. Das ist halt nicht mehr ein Gang und
hat ein Gerät in der Tasche.
SideNode Finger ist ein Kommandozeilen-Tool
von Unix, womit du
nachgucken kannst.
Was hat man damit?
Details zu dem User erfragen.
Genau, da kriegst du User-Informationen auf dem Unix-System raus.
Die ganzen
Studien
ZDH-Accounts
von Studenten
sind alle verbunden mit einem Unix-Account.
Da konntest du dich auf irgendeiner Uni-Kiste einloggen,
Finger von der S-Nummer von irgendjemandem sagen
oder von dem kompletten Namen und dann hast du die S-Nummer
rausgefunden und auch welche Details.
So wie zum Thema Finger.
Der Leon hat letztens im ASCII sitzend in der Uni
von einer TU alle
S-Nummern, also alle Studenten-Accounts
beziehungsweise alle Accounts an der Uni,
also einmal hochgezählt.
An der TU Dresden ist es so, du hast als Student eine S-Nummer,
das ist eine S, und ich weiß gar nicht mehr wie viele,
ich glaube sechs- oder neunstellige Zahl dahinter,
und kannst hochzählen und einfach alle
Accounts durchkrabbeln. Und der ist einfach alle
durchgecrawled und hat den Finger-Output
einfach sich gedumpt lokal.
Und er hat gesehen, du kannst noch so
Plan eintragen. Ich bin echt nicht versiert, was genau
einfach... Du kannst angeben Plan und Project.
Was das ist, ich bin mir gar nicht
gesichert, was da genau der Hintergrund dafür
ist, wenn du das in deine Home-Deal reinlegst.
Eine Punkt-Plan und eine Punkt-Project-Datei, glaube ich.
Der Output davon wird eben bei dem Finger-Output auch mit angegeben.
Und er hat einfach mal geschaut, wer hat eigentlich
alles Custom-Content
im Punkt-Plan drin. Oh, das sind
zehn Leute insgesamt und wir kennen alle.
Bis auf einen. Der Hendrik soll ich.
Oh, der hat da was stehen. Oh, der Kieran-Kölsch.
Der hat da was stehen. Ich hab da irgendwie so
ein Simpsons-Ascii-Art-Zeugs drin.
Du hast Bart, ich habe ein Aski-Art-Bild von mir selber.
Der Dirk hat
als Plan,
World Domination,
Same as everyone's black, Pinky.
Deswegen kennen wir alle Finger.
Wir haben uns einfach alle gegenseitig gefingert die ganze Zeit.
Das kann man nicht sagen.
Das war schön.
Der Flo, ich weiß gar nicht, ob Flo uns hört,
der hat super witzig probiert,
er hat einfach Punkt Plan,
hat er bei sich reingelegt als ein Sim-Link auf Death Random.
Und wenn er sich selber
auf dem Server gefingert hat, dann hat das auch wirklich
DeathRandom dann in sein Terminal gepiped.
Also das Skript
von Leon ging leider dann irgendwie nicht
darüber. Das hat irgendwie...
Das heißt, wenn irgendjemand anders Finger aufruft, dann
printet das bei dem DeathRandom.
Es hat nur bei FlowLocal funktioniert.
Wir haben es nicht debakt, ich weiß nicht, woran das lag,
aber es hat nur...
Wenn er sich selber gefingert hat,
wahrscheinlich hat das irgendwelche rechte Probleme.
Fand ich aber super witzig erstmal.
Wie kann man das System dann wirklich kaputt machen?
Ja, wir linken einfach mal Punktlein.
Also meine S-Nummer wusste ich immer auswendig, die weiß ich auch immer noch auswendig.
Was ich mir nie gemerkt habe, ist meine Matrikelnummer, die du ja eingeben musst,
wenn du irgendwie eine Prüfung schreibst, dann musst du deine Matrikelnummer da draufschreiben.
Genau.
Und da hat der Kilian, der andere Kilian, den wir beide kennen,
der als Mitarbeiter in einem Lehrstuhl arbeitet und Prüfung kontrolliert,
neulich auf Twitter gepostet, dass sein Flash des Tages war,
dass sich irgendein Student seinen Namen und seine Matrikelnummer als Stempel hat hergestellt
und einfach seiner Prüfung mit diesem Stempel
versorgen. Und ich hätte gedacht,
geile Idee, das hat denen bestimmt
10 Euro gekostet, also das kann man echt mal machen,
weil das ist ein geiler Gag. Das ist ein Hack.
Custom Stempel.
Ja, da sag ich dann auch noch etwas zu.
Aber erstmal zum, ähm, da kommen wir
da finden wir was witziges ein, eine witzige Story.
Ähm, zum Telegram-Bot zurück. Ich hab
einen Bot geschrieben, den dürft ihr gerne mal ausprobieren
für die Telegram-Nutzer unter euch. Der heißt
ÖPNV Dresden Bot. Äh, O-E-PNV Dresden Bot.
Ähm,
da wollte ich einfach mal das
DVB-Pi, was ich mal vor einer langen Zeit geschrieben habe,
mal ein bisschen aktualisiert, mal als Telegram-Bot.
Publishing ist auch nicht der einzige Telegram-Bot,
wahrscheinlich der fünfte oder sechste, der
DVB-Daten abgreift.
Aber was ich noch mit machen wollte, ist,
der sollte Natural Language abkönnen. Das heißt,
du sollst dem einfach nur schreiben können, irgendwie
auf welche Art auch immer, keine Ahnung,
was fährt am
zellischen Weg oder wann kommt die
3 am Albertplatz oder sowas
halt dem schreiben können. Und das versteht der eben auch.
Und der dockt eben an,
coolen Service, weil ich nicht clever genug bin,
selber das Machine Learning Modell
dafür zu basteln,
habe ich einen Service, den ich für lange Zeit
benutzt habe, für anderen Kram wiederentdeckt, der eben
genau sowas eben kann. Du schmeißt dem Text hin,
du sagst, was möchtest du denn so an Entities
haben, ob das irgendwelche Intents sind, zum Beispiel
in dem Fall ein Departure-Intent,
der Nutzer sucht Abfahrten,
und dann noch irgendwelche anderen Entities, wie
welche Haltestelle und vielleicht noch irgendwelche Linien,
die da mit drinstehen. Und solches kannst du dem eben
trainieren auf einer Hand von Strings,
Reihe von Strings, um dem sagen, was
an Daten erwartest, du markierst dem eben, was du haben möchtest,
also ganz richtig, so UI,
so für Dumme wie mich, wie kann ich eben
dieses Modell dann eben antrainieren?
Und dann funktioniert das auch einfach richtig gut.
Ich war total geflasht davon.
Ich habe dem, keine Ahnung, 10
verschiedene Beispiele gegeben, die mir
eingefallen sind, habe den hingeschmissen und
der hat plötzlich selbstständig erkennen können,
was für ein Intent das ist, welche Haltestelle,
ob da noch ein Linienfilter dabei ist oder nicht.
Und das funktioniert richtig gut und jetzt kannst du dem Bot eben,
das funktioniert aktuell für Routen und für Abfahrten,
kannst du dem eben schreiben, du möchtest
auf irgendeine Art und Weise, dass es halt irgendwie
natürliche Sprache ist, du suchst Abfahrten an irgendeiner
Haltestelle oder du willst von A nach B, schreibst dem
irgendwie hin und der versteht das.
Das ist richtig, richtig cool.
Ich hab mich immer gefragt, wie man überhaupt APIs
für Natural Language Processing macht, weil
du musst ja quasi
diese Schwammigkeit
wegfiltern können in der API.
Ich kann dir nicht sagen, wenn mir jemand sagt das und das,
du kannst ja
Aussagen über natürliche Sprache eigentlich
auch nur natürliche Sprache ausdrücken.
Naja, nee. Also was Wit AI, was ich da eben nutze, macht, ist, du schmeißt dir einen String hin. Hier nimm mal den Text, das ist ein Endpoint, wo du einfach Text hindumpst und der gibt dir zurück eine Liste von gefundenen Entities und die Entities sind dann halt die Dinge, die du definiert hast als Entities und da sind auch deine Intents mit drin und dann unter dem Key von den mehrjährigen Entities hast du dann eine Liste von den Werten der gefundenen Entities und eine Wahrscheinlichkeit, wie sicher der sich ist mit einem Confidence Value.
wie sicher er sich ist, das gefunden zu haben.
Das ist eigentlich echt ganz gut nutzbar.
Und das funktioniert richtig, richtig gut.
Also wenn jemand mit dem Bot rumspielen möchte,
für Dinge, die er nicht...
Es kann sein, dass es natürlich noch relativ quick to fail ist
bei diversen Anfragen.
Es wird natürlich umso besser, umso mehr verschiedene Anfragen der Bot kennt.
Gerade bei irgendwelchen obskuren Haltestellen,
Namen in Dresden, versteht er manchmal nicht, dass es in der Haltestelle...
Lernt er dann in Production neu dazu,
wenn du ihm mit etwas verschmeißt, wo er eine geringere Certainty hat,
dass er das dann, wenn er eine Nachfrage stellt,
dass er es dann selber lernt?
Das ist bei Wit.ai recht witzig gemacht.
Die landen in der sogenannten Inbox.
Also alle Queries, die der noch nicht exakt so gehört hat,
landen in der Inbox, wo ich die nochmal verifizieren kann,
dass die auch so stimmen.
Und im Notfall halt, sagen wir mal,
in 20 Prozent der Fälle nochmal ein bisschen nachbessern kann aktuell,
von dem, was ich gesehen habe.
Und kann eben sagen, hey, du hast die Haltestelle zur Hälfte richtig erkannt.
Da hat jemand, keine Ahnung, Gustav Freitagstraße geschrieben.
Und der hat Gustav Freitag oder einfach nur Freitagstraße
zum Beispiel als Location erkannt,
was zwar die DVB-API auch dann auf die richtige Haltestelle matcht,
aber du kannst natürlich ein bisschen besser hier, der Marker ist eben
das und das ist die Haltestelle und das da ist die Linie,
da steht jetzt EV8 und nicht
7 und da hat er das EV nicht
mit erkannt oder solche Sachen, solche Kleinigkeiten
nochmal ein bisschen verbessern oder der hat ein Intent
falsch verstanden, was natürlich dann ziemlich doof ist,
aber der lernt dann, die Dinge
werden dann dem Training-Set hinzugefügt und der
nutzt das auch weiter, um darauf neue Erkenntnisse
zu treffen. Das klappt halt dann quasi
in Production einfach immer besser.
Das ist ziemlich cool. Hast du mal diese
Facebook-Library verwendet?
Duckling? Witzigerweise
Die kenne ich auch bloß, weil es ja auf
Hello Swift neulich von Ben als Pick angegeben wurde.
Komplett andersrum.
Wit.ai hat Duckling geschrieben in Closure.
Und Wit.ai
wurde dann irgendwie, ich will nicht sagen gekauft,
ich weiß einfach nicht, was genau dahinter steht.
Die zwei Entwickler, die Wit.ai schreiben, arbeiten
mittlerweile bei Facebook. Und die haben
Duckling in Haskell neu geschrieben.
Und dann habe ich das eben gefunden und Ben hat das gestartet
und jetzt findet der Weg zurück.
Man merkt doch, dass wir verbrüderte Podcasts sind.
Nee, aber Duckling
ist eben genau die Library, die im Untergrund
aus dem erstmal so strukturelle Daten rauszieht
wie Datumsformate und so weiter.
Genau, weil da hast du nämlich dann
plötzlich in den Beispielen gezeigt bekommen, das ist
der Eingangssatz und als Antwort bekommst
du dieses JSON-Konstrukt,
wo du dann plötzlich
bestimmte klassifizierte Daten
drin hast, nämlich da ist eine Location drin,
da ist ein Zeitpunkt drin als
ISO 8601
oder da ist eine bestimmte
Person beschrieben oder sowas. Das ist
dann wieder was, was du in deinem Code dann wieder
ohne dass du mit Natural Language umgehen
musst oder diese Fazziness auch verstehen musst,
dann verwenden kannst du.
Der Kunde hat mir irgendwas gegeben, wo eine Location
drin vorkommt. Also mache ich Location und so.
Das klappt halt halbwegs gut,
also es klappt ziemlich gut im Englischen. In anderen Sprachen
natürlich ist es mehr oder weniger Beta, so wie man
es halt kennt im Internet. Dinge funktionieren immer
am besten auf Englisch. Am besten reden wir alle
auf Englisch und leben nach UTC
und ja egal.
Ich frage mich manchmal, ob ich momentan
nicht sogar mehr Englisch spreche als
ich vornehme, mich auf Arbeit
die ganze Zeit Englisch mit Leuten unterhalte.
Ja, aber Duckling ist auf jeden Fall eine echt coole Library,
die da echt ziemlich viel rauszieht.
Und das nutzt halt With AI Under the Hood,
um da diverse Sachen eben rauszuzerren.
Und das funktioniert echt gut.
Eine weitere Sache, die ich da gerade eben bastel,
die werde ich auch in den nächsten Tagen mal publishen,
ist eine kleine maschinenlesbare JSON-API,
die dir die aktuellen Störinformationen der DVB bereitstellt.
Weil das Problem ist, die DVB,
unsere lokale ÖPNV-Betreiber hier in Dresden,
die Dresdner Verkehrsbetriebe,
die publischen Informationen zu aktuellen Unfällen,
Linienänderungen und so weiter, nur auf Twitter.
Die haben einen Endpoint für Störungen,
aber da posten die nur geplante Dinge.
Also irgendwie eine Baustelle ist da und da
und da wird dann so und so in diesem Zeitraum eine Umleitung sein.
Solche Sachen publischen die bereits maschinensisbar,
sodass deren App in Anführungsstrichen die mobile Webseite
eben das auch mit anzeigen kann, strukturiert.
Aber aktuelle Live-Änderungen, von wegen diese Bahn fällt aus
oder die Haltestelle kann jetzt gerade aufgrund von einem Rettungseinsatz
nicht bedient werden.
diese Sachen publishen die ausschließlich auf Twitter.
Und da habe ich jetzt auch über WoodAI
ein Model antrainiert, was deren Tweets
versteht. Und das funktioniert richtig, richtig gut.
Der versteht exakt, also
ich bin beeindruckt, ich würde
behaupten, aktuell ist das irgendwo in den
hohen 90ern Prozent, wie
gut er diese Tweets versteht, ob das eine Störerinformation
ist, ob das eine Auflösung, also eine Endstörung
ist, ob das Spam ist, weil die einfach
schreiben, ja hier, Hashtag
störungsfrei gehen wir in den Feierabend. Das interessiert mich
natürlich nicht, so ein Tweet. Aber der
erkennt richtig gut aus, was ist das Sentiment
Tweet, ob das jetzt eine Störung ist,
was ist die
Haltestelle, die davon betroffen ist, was sind die
affected Linien,
die von dieser Störung betroffen sind
und das zerrt halt da eben alles raus und das
funktioniert richtig gut und jetzt werde ich einfach die
Twitter, an die Twitter-App mich
ransetzen, die Tweets abgreifen,
maximal noch kombinieren, wenn die manchmal
Dinge über verschiedene Tweets eben abspeisen, aber auch
da haben die, also die halten sich an ein relativ
gutes Format für ihr Twitter-Feed,
das ist den hoch anzurechnen, aber es ist halt trotzdem
nur Twitter und statt Text
Diese Twitter-Fehlermeldungen
sind auch der Hauptgrund, warum ich diesen
Twitter-Account abonniert habe. Ich habe das auch mal zeitweise
mit Notifications an abonniert
gehabt, aber dadurch, dass wir noch wesentlich
uninteressanteres Sachen da posten,
habe ich es dann auch wieder abbestellt. Das ist schade.
Du könntest halt maximal irgendwie dann
RegEx-basiert rangehen und sagen, dich interessiert
diese Haltestelle und diese Linie. Schön wäre es, wenn sie
zwei Twitter-Accounts hätten. Wenn sie einfach für solche
zeitakuten... Ja, oder halt einfach
kein Twitter-Feed dafür, sondern halt irgendwie
direkt was Besseres. Direkt, wenn
ja solche Sachen... Liebe DVB,
wenn ihr solche Sachen auf Twitter veröffentlicht,
zum Beispiel an der
Walpurgusstraße fährt die
Linie 3 heute nicht,
bitte nehmen sie den Schienenersatzverkehr
oder so weiter und so fort. Oder wir haben
montags ab und zu hier so einen Karnevalsverein, der
durch Dresden spaziert und der auch
den öffentlichen Nahverkehr massiv
beeinträchtigt,
dann macht doch dafür bitte extra einen
Endpoint auf eurer Seite. Ja, wie gesagt, wir haben ja schon
die Störungsdaten und das wäre doch so schön,
wenn die App, das ist genau das, was ich gerade baue,
eine App, die dir Push-Notifications schickt,
wenn du von dir abonnierte Linien oder Haltestellen
irgendwie aktuell von der Störung betroffen sind.
Und sowas hätte ich gerne in der offiziellen App mit drin.
Die offizielle App ist zwar Schrott, das haben wir da hingestellt,
aber sowas hätte ich gerne als Feature.
Und dann baue ich das halt jedem selber.
Da hast du doch bestimmt einfach noch einen Twitter-Bot dazu.
Was habe ich da wieder gekonnt?
Da hast du einen Twitter-Bot,
der nur die Störungsmeldung retweetet.
Aber dann in einem sehr wohl definierten Format.
Das auf jeden Fall.
Damit man da wirklich...
Ja, warum nicht?
Wo ich sagen muss, ich gebe momentan Telegram auch wieder eine zweite Chance.
Also ich habe es jetzt tatsächlich auch eine Zeit lang wieder deinstalliert gehabt,
aber als du mich neulich darüber in Kenntnis gesetzt hast,
dass es da plötzlich einen zweiten Twitter-Client gibt,
äh, Quatsch, Telegram, Telegram, Telegram.
Dass es einen zweiten Telegram-Client gibt, nämlich TelegramX,
wo ich erst gedacht habe, das ist fake,
weil man siehst ja manchmal so Fake-Apps im Play Store,
gebe ich dem momentan auch wieder eine Chance.
Jetzt habe ich zwar eine Zeit lang, weil ich beide Clients installiert habe,
jede Nachricht auch zweimal als Notification gehabt,
Einmal mit Telegram und einmal mit Telegram X.
Aber gerade mit solchen Bots würde ich das langsam wieder in Erwägung ziehen.
Telegram hat eine echt coole Bot-API, muss ich sagen.
Telegram ist klein, muss man immer noch mal dahingestellt.
Immerhin versuchen sie gerade mit Telegram X
weg von ihren ursprünglichen kremlnahen Wurzeln zu kommen.
Keine Ahnung, was da eigentlich dahinter steckt.
Wahrscheinlich ist das auch totaler Quatsch, was ich gerade sage.
Aber zumindest schien es immer so nach außen,
dass sie da irgendwo durch einen neuen Inhaber von V-Kontakte
da sehr, sehr eigenartige Veranwandlungen haben.
Und sie ziehen jetzt gerade mit ihrer Firma komplett in die UK um.
Und deswegen gibt es auch Telegram X, was einfach eine Neuimplementation ist.
Aber technisch sind die halt, also mal abgesehen von Krypto,
die immer noch fehlt auf dieser Kack-Plattform.
Echt?
Das ist halt alles unverschlüsselt.
Du hast ausschließlich Transportverschlüsselung.
Das ist der große, große, große, große Nachteil von Telegram.
Aber ansonsten sind die Clients halt einfach beeindruckend.
Die sind unglaublich schnell.
Sie sind nativ auf allen Plattformen, die ich nutze.
Der Desktop-Client ist nativ auf macOS, auf allen anderen Plattformen.
Die müssen ja auch nicht den ganzen Umstand mit Krypto machen.
Deswegen können sie immer schnell einen guten Client schreiben.
Vielleicht ist es das, aber die Clients funktionieren halt
so gut. Die sind so schnell und so
angenehm und die Bot-AP ist echt beeindruckend.
Der Bot kann dir eine Liste,
so eine Custom-Keyboard eben hinlegen.
Du kannst dem ÖPNV Dresden-Bot
kannst du deine Location schicken, der schickt dir eine Liste
von den nächsten Haltestellen, du tippst die an, der sagt dir,
was da abfährt. Das ist doch
unglaublich nice, ist Interaktion mit dem Bot.
Auf jeden Fall. Das ist unglaublich angenehm.
Im Endeffekt ist ja ein Instant Messenger
auf die Art und Weise nur eine andere Form
von Kommandozeile. Ja, genau das ist eben
mein Punkt gewesen. Genau. Genau das
will ich damit auch sagen. Und bevor mir jetzt jemand sagt...
Es ist schade, dass sie das Rad neu erfunden haben, weil wie gesagt, das konnte man ja
vor 15 Jahren mit Jabba schon machen, aber
wer benutzt schon noch Jabba heutzutage? Ja, und ich will
bitte auch niemandem hier auf die Füße treten, der meint, ja,
Telegram hat Krypto. Ja, es hat
Secret Chats, aber die nutzt keine Sau, weil sie einerseits
nicht Standard sind und andererseits... Krypto hat gefälligst,
fucking Default zu sein. Ja, es ist nicht Standard und andererseits
lockt es dich auf den jeweiligen Client, den du aktuell
benutzt. Und das ist halt auch Schrott. Ich will
Multi-Client,
Cross-Plattform. Also nicht, dass hier der Eindruck
entsteht, dass wir in jeder Folge
einen neuen Messenger-Service
promoten. Meine persönliche
Empfehlung ist immer noch, benutzt entweder
Signal oder Wire.
Wenn man auf Wire oder Signal
diese Bot-API hätte, wie bei
Wire hat eine Bot-API.
Das entwickelt sich langsam.
Das ist eine relativ dicke Java-Library,
wo du halt die komplette Krypto auch kleinseitig
machen musst. Das ist halt klar, der Bot
muss halt auch die Krypto sprechen.
Das ist halt echt nicht ohne und nicht so trivial,
damit was anzufangen zu...
Nee, dann ist es noch nicht da. Das muss
genauso einfach sein wie ohne Krypto.
Das stimmt. Auf jeden Fall.
Nee, aber wenn jemand Bock hat,
gerne mal den ÖPNV Dresdenbot
anschreiben und mal schauen, wie ihr das findet.
Der hat auch, wenn ihr nicht die Natural Language nutzen wollt,
einfach Slash A oder Slash Abfahrten
und dann Haltestelle, dann
bypass das direkt mit.ai und das geht
nur direkt an die DVB-RP,
um Abfahrten abzufragen. Sowas geht auch.
Die Routen kann man nur über natürliche Sprache machen,
weil da immer die Syntax einfach zu komplizieren aufzustellen.
Und ich hätte mal so ein Back-and-forth,
kannst du auch so einen Conversation-Handler
dann da hin und her schicken, wo du dann immer wieder
quasi so ein State-Object
zwischen Client und Bot hin und her reichst,
damit du dich durch so eine Konversation mit dem Bot
hängen willst, aber das ist mir zu komplex gewesen.
Das erinnert mich daran, dass es so ziemlich genau
mein allererstes Ruby-Projekt war, nämlich ein Jabber-Bot,
den du fragen konntest, nach welchen Haltestellen
jetzt als nächstes welche Sachen anfangen.
War das Catch-My-Buzz?
Nee, das war noch vor Catch-My-Buzz.
Cool.
Nee, aber ja, genau.
Telegram-Bots. Ich habe Spaß daran,
generell an Chatbots.
Vielleicht haben das viele Leute, vielleicht ist der
Chat-Obs-Hype schon durch. Gibt es schon einen
Parken-DD-Chatbot? Ich habe tatsächlich kurz
drüber nachgewacht. Ich habe sogar, um zu
prokrastinieren, einen Campus-Navigator-Telegram-Bot
geschrieben, den du
fragen kannst, wo bestimmte Dinge sind. Und der
schickt dir eine Location. Wenn jetzt natürlich
in Telegram als nächstes noch drin wäre,
dass du einfach, ich meine, du kannst ja ohne weiteres
deine Textnachrichten, die du schickst, einfach
diktieren. Wenn du
ein Modus sein könntest, wo du sagst, ich diktiere
hier Textnachrichten und wenn ich eine
diktiert habe, dann wird mir die nächste direkt
vorgelesen, dann hast du quasi
so ein Home Assistant gebaut.
Ja, prinzipiell.
Nicht viel mehr als das.
Du könntest es auch einfach in eine Skill rappen.
Dann hast du so eine Alexa-Skill.
Da muss man ja so ein Abhörzylinder irgendwo rumstehen haben.
Witzige Nebengeschichte.
Wir hatten so eine
Ansprache von unserem CEO
im Dezember.
Ja, das Jahr ist so und so gelaufen.
Und ich wünsche euch allen frohe Weihnachten,
guten Rutsch und kleine
Side-Notes. Hier, und dann hält da so
ein Amazon Echo hoch.
Jeder Mitarbeiter kriegt ein Amazon Echo jetzt
zu Weihnachten geschenkt.
Wir haben die immer noch nicht.
Würdest du eins hier hinstellen?
Ich würde damit mal eine Runde rumspielen.
Ich würde mir das, wenn ich mir das in der Wohnung
stellen würde, höchstens in den Raum stehen, wo ich nicht
viel Zeit verbringe. Vielleicht im Bad oder sowas,
aber ich glaube nicht, dass ich es dauerhaft, ich weiß es nicht.
Da bin ich noch zu. Also ich würde tatsächlich
ich auch, also meine Eltern haben daheim so ein Ding.
Ich bin
dahingestellt, da bin ich nicht sehr oft, deswegen
ist mir das relativ wurscht, aber
abgehört wollen wir noch nicht.
Wir haben irgendwie alle so ein bisschen die Hoffnung
aufgegeben, unsere Eltern noch auf den gleichen
Aufklärungslevel, was
Privatsphäre angeht.
Der Aspekt war komplett dahingestellt.
Das Ding ist
nett. Die Spracherkennung
ist erstaunlich gut.
Das hat mich echt überrascht.
Du sitzt auf der anderen Seite des Raums, es läuft noch
Fernseher nebenbei oder Leute unterhalten sich und du
sagst einfach auf normalen Lautstärke mittendrin irgendwie
Hey Alexa, mach mal das und das.
Das ist eigentlich das, was am gruseligsten ist, weil das weiß
nämlich genau, dass sie dich genauso gut versteht.
In manchen
Agentenfilmen machen die Leute einen Wasserhahn
an und reden dann dabei weiter,
damit... Das stimmt eigentlich, das ist absolut
an Absurdumgefühl. Und wenn das Ding
sauber das Fernsehprogramm
von deiner Stimme unterscheiden kann
und dann auch noch du nicht mal laut
explizit in diese Richtung sprechen musst, dann weißt du genau,
das ist eigentlich egal, in welcher Situation
jedes Wort, was du sprichst, mitloggen kann.
Wow.
War schön gekuselt.
Mir ist auch noch was anderes
ein bisschen Witziges eingefallen. Dadurch das Parken DD,
ihr habt es ja auch nie umbenannt,
das heißt wirklich noch Parken DD,
das ist aber mittlerweile so eine internationale App,
die mehrere Städte unterstützt.
Das kotzt mich so an. Ich hätte es so gerne schon lange umbenannt.
Das ist quasi die gleiche History wie
DDWRT genommen hat.
Was ja diese freie
Router-Software ist, die man sich auf seinen Router
flashen konnte.
Das hat irgendwie in Dresden da durchgeführt?
Und das DD steht für Dresden.
Ja, aber der Witz ist ja,
das Parken DD, das DD steht
lange nicht mehr wie Dresden, das steht für
eine Inside-Joke
und zwar, das steht für Parken da und dort.
Stimmt. Einfach Quatsch.
Ich hätte das schon so gerne umbenannt,
wenn irgendwer einen Vorschlag hat, bitte her damit.
Aber dadurch, dass das Parken DD jetzt vor zwei Wochen
oder vor einer Woche schon wieder in der SZ war,
verliere ich die Hoffnung, dass wir das Projekt
irgendwann umbenannt bekommen. Also wir haben wenig aktive
Nutzer, aber das interessiert mich auch nicht.
Aber wenn Leute das unter dem Namen
dann ist es jetzt zu spät.
Du kannst seit Anfang an...
Ist halt auch catchy irgendwie parken.
Ich finde den Namen scheiße.
Ach, man gewöhnt sich dran.
Jetzt lieber Open Park oder so.
Oder Open Parking.
Libre Parking.
Nein, schrecklich.
Nee, da gibt es einfach...
Free as in Free Parking.
Oh man, das sind so lange,
sind da fünf Städte drin.
Und das merkt halt,
das weiß halt einfach niemand.
Das war seit Anfang an,
gibt es Support für Ingolstadt.
Da gibt es keinen einzigen Nutzer.
Andere nennen ihre Software PIVIC
oder...
Das merkt sich nicht mal einer.
Bei Parken DD kannst du dir merken,
das kommt aus Dresden, deswegen heißt es DD.
Witzigerweise
müsste Dresden
nicht das Kennzeichen DD haben. Eigentlich müsste Dresden
das Kennzeichen D haben und
Düsseldorf müsste DD haben und nicht D.
Wusstest du, dass es die TLD
DD gibt? Also die ist reserviert
für DDR, aber da die DDR nicht mehr existiert,
darf die niemand mehr haben?
Ich wette, das ist garantiert
Wetten, dass es so ein paar
Right-Wing-Nerds gibt,
die sich unbedingt
Pegida.de registrieren wollen.
Ich meine, Dresden hätte echt
Useful.de, aber dann
ja. Also manche Städte
haben ja extrem kurze
kurze Sachen, zum Beispiel
Leipzig hat
L.de und Köln.
Ach, du meinst der Domain, der hat der Schad?
Wirklich, Domain, Name, nicht die Top-Level-Domain,
aber wirklich kurze Domain.
kölnhatk.de. Krass.
Das geht. Aber da brauchst du halt,
musst du halt schon sagen, du bist hier eine Stadt.
Ja, aber ich meine, die sind ja nicht reserviert oder so.
Alle Single Level. Nee, aber wenn du dir
bei der DENIC eine Domain registrieren willst,
dann gibt es ein paar Regeln für
den allgemeinen Bürger. Also die dürfen nicht mit
Zahlen anfangen und die müssen mindestens
viertstellig sein.
Drei. Oder mindestens dreistellig sein.
Also ich kenne Leute ja dreistellig. Aber dreistellige kriegst du
nicht mehr. Nee, ganz vergessen. Lange weg.
Na wohl, da gab es
26 hoch 3
Aber wo wir gerade über Pegida-Spaßvögel gesprochen haben, kennst du die Webseite wirsindafd.de?
Nee, was ist das?
Das ist einfach eine Seite von jemandem, die sind hauptsächlich ein bisschen in der Presse gelandet, weil sie halt von der AfD verklagt wurden über die Namensrechte.
Die Seite heißt wirsindafd.de und der Untertitel ist
Wir sind eine rechtsextreme, rassistische, menschenverachtende Partei und wir sitzen unter anderem im Deutschen Bundestag.
Und was dies ist, ist einfach eine Zitatsammlung mit Zitaten, die AfD-Mitglieder und Abgeordnete irgendwann mal gesagt haben.
Stark.
Wo einfach hier zum Beispiel Björn Höcke, MDL, die Evolution hat Afrika und Europa vereinfacht gesagt zwei unterschiedliche Reproduktionsstrategien beschert, hat Björn Höcke irgendwann mal gesagt.
Ich finde es schön, dass auf dieser Seite das einfach mal so ein bisschen zusammengetragen wird.
der dritte Eintrag von oben,
das geht ja einfach chronologisch um, in eigener Sache,
ich bin von der AfD verklagt worden, die diese
Domain für sich reklamiert, in Klammern siehe
Pressemitteilung. Ich bin zuversichtlich,
dass es in Deutschland erlaubt sein muss,
unter einer gut auffindbaren Domain
Überäußerungen von Politikern aufzuklären.
Das Gericht hat in der ersten Instanz
zugunsten der AfD entschieden,
Klammern Urteil Pressemitteilung.
Eine Freundin hat einen Spendetopf organisiert,
damit ich die Prozesskosten nicht alleine tragen muss.
Ich freue mich über jede Unterstützung.
Cool.
Das ist eine coole
Seite. Ich kenne jetzt, ich weiß überhaupt nichts
über denjenigen, der sie betreibt.
Eventuell sind die auch in
Netzpolitik.org mal erwähnt worden, aber wenn nicht,
dann werden sie es vielleicht noch, aber schaut euch das mal an,
wenn ihr damit einverstanden seid
oder euch damit identifizieren könnt.
Das sind in den Shownotes
verlinkt.
So viel dazu. Das war die Polit-Sektion
unserer Welt.
Achso, die eine Sache, die ich vorhin ansprechen wollte, Custom-Stempel.
Da füllen wir noch was Witziges ein.
Es gibt übrigens auch Stempel DD, da haben wir die Stempel für das ASCII bestellt.
Oh Mann.
Nee, bist du vertraut mit diesem Eurion-Zeichen, wie auch immer man das ausspricht?
Nein.
Das ist so eine Konstellation aus fünf Punkten, die auf jedem Euroschein drauf ist.
Und diese Konstellation auf fünf Punkte oder fünf Kreisen macht es eben aus,
dass du einen Euroschein zumindest auf hoherwertigen Kopierern nicht kopieren kannst
beziehungsweise auf höherwertigen Druckern nicht ausdrucken kannst.
Zum Beispiel der Drucker, den ich zur Verfügung habe,
der ist so dumm, der macht einfach alles.
Aber High-End-Drucker,
so wie das Ding, was wir in der Uni beim ZDH
im Plot-Service rumstehen haben,
da habe ich mal getestet.
Ich habe einen 50-Euro-Schein auf den Kopierer gelegt
und da kam eine Seite Tonart aus.
Das war quasi fast 50 Euro wert.
So als Strafe, dass du das versucht hast.
Aber fand ich super cool.
Und das erkennt das eben halt
an diesem fünfstelligen Muster aus den Kreisen.
Kannst einfach mal googeln.
Wie heißt das?
so wie A-U-R-I-O-N.
Orion.
Genau, ich weiß wahrscheinlich wie Orion angelehnt.
Ah ja, tatsächlich.
Und diese Konstellation macht das eben aus.
Und was ich mal probiert habe, hat leider nicht so gut gestattet.
Stimmt, ja, das habe ich gesehen.
Aber meine Absicht war, genau dieses Muster als Stempel zu drucken,
ungefähr der Größe von einem Euroschein,
in der Farbe, wie es auch da erkannt wird,
also dieses Orion-Gelb-Grün.
Und einfach auf jegliche Sachen an Ämter, die ich nicht mag.
Das könnte eventuell sogar so ein bisschen an das Sternzeichen Orion angelehnt sein.
Vielleicht ist es sogar genau das, ich weiß es nicht.
Ich kümmere mich da nicht aus.
Aber auf Unterlagen für Enter, die ich nicht mag,
wie das Immeramt oder das Finanzamt,
eben alle überall mit drauf zu stempeln,
so unscheinbar in irgendwelche Ecken,
und dann einfach richtig angenervt,
wenn die versuchen, diese Sachen zu kopieren, da einzuscannen.
Jedes Mal, wenn du irgendwo einen Abzug von deinem Ausweis hinschicken musst.
Ich hätte so viel Spaß.
Ich habe mir das Ding bestellt gehabt, es funktionierte leider nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, woran es lag.
Vielleicht war es nicht filigran genug.
Zu fuzzy.
Zu groß.
Es war genau das Muster.
Ist das geschützt? Könnte man sich das vielleicht in irgendwelche Logos einbauen?
Dass du es im Briefkopf hast?
Aber nur, wenn du deine eigenen Angestellten richtig anbissen möchtest.
Aber ich fand das super witzig.
Wenn er irgendwann mal Bock hat, die Idee umzusetzen und das macht, das funktioniert,
bitte schickt mir Fotos.
Ich gebe euch Geld und ich will so einen Stempel haben, mit dem das funktioniert.
Wir lassen uns ja sonst nichts von unseren Hörern schicken.
Aber wenn ihr euch so einen Stempel machen lasst, dann hätte ich gerne auch einen.
Wie gesagt, ich gebe Geld dafür.
Ich will, dass das funktioniert.
Ich habe es, wie gesagt, nicht hinbekommen.
Meiner war nicht filigran genug, vermute ich.
Oder die falsche Farbe.
Ich habe einfach nur so einen Online-Stempeldruckservice genommen.
Der war halt relativ klein und der war auch in grün.
Und ich meine, das hätte theoretisch funktionieren können,
aber es hat leider nicht geklappt.
Und wenn jemand wüsste, woran es vielleicht liegen könnte,
immer nachher mit den Ideen.
Hast du mal die Wikipedia-Seite dazu aufgemacht?
Ja.
Die Eureon-Konstellation?
Das ist auch auf 20-Dollar-Noten drauf.
Ach so, das ist nicht nur der Euro?
Angeblich ist es auf den aktuellen 20-Dollar-Noten.
Da stehen im Hintergrund, hast du so frei verteilt ein paar Zwanzigen auf der Zwanziger-Note.
Und die Nullen sind alle so angeordnet, die Zwanzigen sind alle so angeordnet, dass die Nullen diese Konstellation ergeben.
Und the following table lists the banknotes in which the Urian constellation has been found so far.
Und das ist eine ziemlich lange Liste.
Auf dem armenischen Dramm, auf dem arubischen Florin.
Da kommen currencies drin vor, die ich noch gar nicht kenne.
Schilling, auf dem österreichischen Austrian Dollar,
Belgian Frank, British Pound.
Das ist fast auf jeder Währung drauf, ja.
Genau. Und diese SVG, die auf dem Wikipedia-Artikel
ist, die habe ich direkt drucken lassen. Genau diese SVG.
Aber da müsste ja theoretisch
die Größe auch vollkommen
wurscht sein. Ich weiß es halt nicht.
Farbe theoretisch auch. Ich weiß halt nicht, woran
es liegt, wie gesagt. Ich habe den Stempel
auch wahrscheinlich irgendwo noch rumliegen.
Wollen wir noch mal ein bisschen mit rumspielen.
Cool. Aber fand ich
witzig. Und wenn da jemand eine Idee hat, warum das nicht geklappt hat,
bitte her damit, ich will, dass das funktioniert.
Ich finde, ich mag die Idee.
Gut.
Wollen wir
in dieser Sendung noch, ich meine, wir haben
jetzt extrem viele Sachen, lustige Sachen
aufgezählt, die wir kennen. Wollen wir noch ein paar Picks aufzählen?
Klar. Hast du was?
Ich hab was. Du hast
bereits vid.ai aufgezählt.
Genau, das würde ich auch gerne mit meinen dritten
Pick mit reinschmeißen.
Cooler Service. Wie gesagt, läuft
bei Facebook, deswegen
sollte man sich bloß im Hinterkopf behalten.
aber ich finde es trotzdem, es gibt auch andere Sachen, du kannst auch
keine Ahnung, Microsoft Azure
Language Processing nutzen
es läuft halt bei Weipen nicht so
angenehm und mit viel mehr drumrum
und tamtam, bis du das zum Laufen kriegst
aber gerade die UI von WIT zum
Antrainieren von deinem Model, habe ich super cool gefunden
toller Service
gefällt mir, ziemlich schick
ich habe natürlich wieder
eine kleine Kommandozeilen
UI
nämlich TUI-RS
da hat mich hauptsächlich geflasht, was die
coole Sachen in der Kommandozeile damit bauen.
Also das ist, damit baut man Terminal-UIs,
nicht Kommandozeilen-Sachen.
Das hat nichts mit dem Reiseanbieter TUI zu tun.
Nee, ich habe auch heute gesehen, es gibt noch eine andere Library,
die heißt FUI.
Aber mit TUI kann man interaktive
Dashboards bauen, wo irgendwelche Balkendiagramme
oder irgendwelche Sinuskurven drin laufen
oder Weltkarten, die sind
größer skalierbar.
Ist das responsive?
Holy crap, ist das geil.
Das sieht eigentlich ziemlich schick aus.
Damit möchte man mal was bauen.
Das bringt ein paar Witches mit, nämlich
Blockdiagramme, Gauges,
Bar-Clients, Charts, Bar-Charts,
Lists, Tables, Paragraphs,
Canvases für Line
und Point Clouds
und Maps.
Und du kannst Sachen in Tabs
anordnen. Boah, ist das cool.
Ziemlich schick. Also ich hab's noch nicht benutzt, aber
wenn das das hält, was es verspricht, dann ist das
ziemlich cool. Also ich würde gerne mal so ein
Grafana-Board damit umsetzen.
Ich hab Bock, was damit
zu machen. Ich probier's gerne für Swift,
aktuelle Projekte.
Raps doch einfach. Hast du schon mal
eine Swift... Hast du schon mal damit rumgespielt,
einfach Rust-Sachen zu rappen
und in Swift einzuporen? Nicht Rust, aber klar,
wenn du eine externe C-Abi
hast und da eine Module-Map
für Swift daneben blickst, ist das eigentlich kein Ding.
Ich hätte ganz so was wie Bindgen für Swift.
Bindgen ist ein geiles Rust-Tool.
Kann man doch machen.
Also ich habe jetzt ein bisschen Erfahrung mit Code-Generatoren.
Du hast ja noch was aufgelistet, nämlich
Xonsch.
Ich habe Xonsch mit dabei. Genau, Xonsch
ist eine Shell, die
tatsächlich super cool finde.
Neben der Tatsache, dass du auch
normales Shell-Kram damit machst,
halt einfach quasi ein Python-Rubble mit ist.
Also eine
Shell, bloß dass ich meine
Skripte nicht in Bash schreiben
muss, sondern in Python. Genau, und du kannst
halt inline in deiner Shell einfach Python ausführen.
Und es ist super angenehm, weil Python halt auch einfach
im Vergleich zu anderen Shell-Sprachen
eine super verständliche, einfache, zugängliche
Syntax hat.
Bis du echt drei ineinander geschachtelte
Comprehensions lesen musst.
Klar, also ich meine, du kannst natürlich auch echt ekelhaft werden.
Vor allem geschachtelte Comprehensions.
Nee, sorry, da hört's auf.
Das ist also ziemlich gut in line
mit Shell.js, was ich glaube ich
vor ein paar Folgen mal gepickt hatte.
Aber super
cool, die Xont. Und ich würde gerne
mal mehr darauf umsteigen und mal versuchen
ein bisschen produktiver mit zu sein. Finde ich
cool. Ansonsten bin ich mit seiner Setscher echt glücklich,
aber sonst sieht echt schick aus.
Gefällt mir von der Idee her super cool.
Kannst du mir gleich mal nach der Sendung vorführen.
Genau, was anderes, was ich noch
mitgepickt habe, machen wir gleich mal weiter, ist
ein Python-Projekt, das heißt VideoGrab.
Und macht genau das, was du denkst, was es macht.
Du hast Grab für Videos.
Und es ist unglaublich krass.
Vor allem, einerseits basiert
das erstmal darauf, dass du dir Untertiteldateien brauchst.
Warte mal, ist das Kommandozeilen-Tool? Ja.
Und das greppt wonach? Was gibst du da ein?
Bild von Gesicht von...
Nee, Text.
Geschprochenen Text.
Ach, gesprochenen Text.
Genau. Und der hat zwei Modi.
Zum einen nutzt er eine Untertitel-Datei
und der gibt dir halt aus ein Videoschnipsel,
wo das gesagt wird, was du nachher, was du greppst.
Unglaublich cool.
Kann man gute Meme-Generatoren oder GIF-Generatoren mitbauen.
Zum Beispiel.
Und der zweite Modi, der ist zum Beispiel auch gerappt in...
Die haben auch eine Beta-Mac UI, die Video-Grab-Rappt.
Das ist ziemlich cool.
der nutzt einfach mal Python, Magic
irgendwelche Bibliotheken, die da
irgendwelche Magic, Bad Magic Spracherkennung drauf werfen
und du scheißt auch, du hast keinen Untertitel,
egal, ich generiere mir erstmal Untertitel und dann
grappe ich in den. Auch super cool.
Das ist cool, aber wenn es für Video
geht, geht es natürlich wahrscheinlich auch für Audio, könnten wir
damit einfach für Podcasts Untertitel
generieren? Podcast Untertitel.
Ja, Spracherkennung geht ja auch.
Na, Transcriptions.
Für Spracherkennung geht ja so oder so schon.
Video Grab ist ja explizit dafür da, dass du in Videos
scrappst. Aber ich bin darüber
gestoßen über MoviePie.
MoviePie ist eine coole Bibliothek, die alles abstrahiert
mit Videodateien.
Und da war unter anderem gelistet, hey, hier gibt es auch VideoCrap.
Boah, das klingt cool. Das ist genau so,
was du denkst, was das ist. Super cool.
Das war gerade voll witzig.
Wir sind allein.
Sehr gut.
Was hast du noch, Icepick?
Ja, eine ganz kleine Sache. Ich meine,
einfach Tools, die man jeden Tag benutzen kann.
Viele Sachen, die ich aufzähle,
sind auch solche Libraries, die ich selber nicht verwendet habe.
aber was zum Beispiel ein schöner Service ist,
ist send.firefox.com.
Denn das war eine Zeit lang
aus deren Testpilotprogramm
einfach so ein Versuch
und mittlerweile läuft der Service einfach weiter.
Also geht einfach mal auf send.firefox.com,
da kann man sich gegenseitig Dateien schicken, der eine lädt sie
hoch und kann dann einen Link jemand anders schicken.
Wir haben das für mindestens drei akronomisierbare
Folgen verwendet, weil ich
die nämlich meistens in letzter Zeit schneide
und Kilian die dann bei Auphonic hochlädt
und dann habe ich quasi den Rohschnitt
300 Megabyte Flag-Datei einfach
da reingeschmissen. Das Maximum ist, glaube ich, ein Gigabyte.
Ich glaube, zwei
ab Gigabyte waren sie dich oder irgendwie sowas.
Genau, und die werden, du lädst
die hoch und die werden beim Hochladen
im Browser verschlüsselt und beim
Runterladen im Browser entschlüsselt.
Das ist auf jeden Fall nicht Peer-to-Peer. Es lädt auf Firefox-Server irgendwo hoch.
Genau, es ist nicht Peer-to-Peer. Es ist jetzt nicht sowas
wie Filepizza oder
dann gibt es noch Attach oder
Deattach. Da gab es auch so einen anderen Dienst.
Genau, und die Dateien
werden automatisch nach
entweder einem Tag oder
einem Download gelöscht. Man kann aber auch
anklicken, ich möchte, dass das zweimal runtergeladen
werden kann oder dreimal runtergeladen werden kann.
Aber es wird alles immer spätestens nach
24 Stunden gelöscht.
Was ziemlich schön ist.
Genau.
Das waren die Picks.
Wollen wir es damit ausklingen lassen?
Schließen wir damit mal Folge 015
ist das, glaube ich. Folge 015.
Schließen wir die Namen mal ab? Strikt versioniert
nach unserem semantischen
semantischen Podcast-Versioning-Scheme.
Ah, wir können Podcast-Seasons als
Minor-Version-Bumps 0.2.
Das hatte der Change-Log
ja eine Zeit lang. Die Versionen hießen
0.1, 0.2.
Folge 10 war Version
0.1.0. Das haben wir, glaube ich, nach
100 Folgen eingeladen. Und was macht man dann mit
Folge 0.1.10?
Gab's nicht.
Die haben einfach
die Versionen, die haben einfach die
Episoden hochgezählt
und zwischen jede Zeit ein Punkt gemacht.
Ja, ne, unser
Versioning-Scheme ist ziemlich klar.
Das hier war jetzt Folge
AKB 015.
Genau.
Für Feedback und Anmerkungen
freuen wir uns natürlich gerne auf unserer neuen Webseite.
Haben wir letztes Mal schon angesprochen.
Akronomisier.bar. Da gibt es sogar Kommentare
über Discuss unter jeder Folge.
Ansonsten schreibt uns einfach auf Twitter.
Schreibt uns einfach auf Twitter. Wir sind sogar seit kurzem
auf Instagram.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ihr uns da folgen müsst,
weil wir da garantiert nichts Sinnvolles veröffentlichen werden.
Wir sind bloß mal von irgendwem gementioned worden auf Instagram
und Klayan hat es für notwendig erhalten.
Ich fand es witzig.
Ich werde danach einfach ab jetzt mein Mittagessen posten.
Dann werde ich Hendrik beim Mittagessen Essen posten.
Genau, vielen Dank, dass ihr uns bis hierhin zugehört habt.
Und der nächste Podcast in eurer Playlist beginnt in 3, 2, 1...